all right and we are
live the last word with lore cognitive
and igbotis
friday morning spicy
campfire if i must add you know we got a
lot to talk about
e before we uh talk about our great
guest that has come joining us once
again
how have you been doing sir uh i'm good
i got up at like 4 30 this morning got a
workout in so
started early got my second dose this
week so i already got punched in the arm
once
um so overall been doing pretty good um
just kind of a weird week as we were
kind of making sure nothing went too
crazy so it took it later in the week
but other than that yeah yesterday it
just exploded so
we gotta we gotta talk about this but
before we do quick uh
quick bring in of our friend of the show
the man who always shows up dressed to
impress and cannot get his uh look at
him
cannot even get him to start moving and
bobbing and weaving he's gonna be
throwing shots today across the bow
straight into the boat sir thai guy
travis man we are happy to have you here
thank you for joining us at the crack of
dawn by the way what time is it there
for you right now
it is now 606 a.m i woke up at 5
18 because i had a dream i was going to
miss the show
and it woke me up welcome back to this
cold sweat like i don't
i do that i have paddocks like i
oversleep important things yeah all the
time
yeah i get up too early yep so i had a
dream i missed the show i woke up at 5
18.
barely had enough time to get ready and
do my little setup here and
here we are ready to get ready for some
fire takes see this is this is
dedication though 5
18 gets up 606 in the morning sun may
not even be up where is that but he is
still
definitely not dressed to the knights
like right california california's
the sun in california is lazy i don't
think it's up to like 10 am here
that sounds like it goes right along
with the beach bum crew so you know it's
all good
look first of all thank you for coming
brother cause you it when this topic
went down and i saw
your twitter i said oh
it's gonna be spicy travis in here it's
gonna be lit
so i'm glad you can make it thank you
for getting up early so we really
appreciate it
so just a light show right feel good
vibes right everything's good
you know positive things are coming the
shader system is going to be getting
improvements to it you know we're
actually going to be able to
not have to deal with consumables and
that pretty much crosses off a list of
the positives now
i mean it almost does so we got a lot of
information so
i i think we just have to start with the
bomb because guardian games we can cover
after which is its own thing but
twab yesterday dropped and the big news
was armor synthesis which is a creative
way to say transmog
and we got news of how it was gonna work
and a couple complicated things
before i even get into the nitty gritty
of reading out literally what it says
um travis i want your take first i mean
i don't think you even finished reading
it before you had to go take a walk or
something like please
tell us like how did yesterday go for
you
well yesterday i checked out the twab
and when i got to the point where they
were adding three more currencies that
all had the word
synth in it i literally just side
facepalmed stood and started pacing
around my room like
what in the god what in god's name is
happening right now
so that like took me from back just just
from the set like
it it's it's crazy to me
like we'll get into all the details and
the weeds of like how
like messed up the system is but
honestly like
i was wondering for like a year why is
taking transmog so long
because to me like i mean i'm not a
developer man i don't want to like
oversimplify it but like
it seems like it could have been one
button that just said add to armor
collections
you know or or they could have just made
you know armor ornaments
in the collections tab a little bit
bigger and added all the ones that you
have automatically there or some system
like that
that allowed you to access it and so i
was just like like why is it taking so
long
and then seeing their system it is so
complicated three new currencies
a new system of bounties uh a new
you know way to buy them which requires
a separate currency that you have to
purchase
the the way that they're applied and and
the limited amount that you do every
season which is actually
fewer armor sets than they're
introducing each season which means no
matter what you're going to fall behind
unless you pay
all that stuff and i'm just sitting
there like guys it was one button
press x to pay respects it was that
like literally it reminded me
like this is a weird analogy but have
you ever seen that episode of rick and
morty where
it turns out that we find out that rick
has an entire civilization living inside
his car engine
just to give his car battery that's what
reminded me
like bungie made it so complicated to do
such a simple thing like they literally
built a whole
a whole economy and a whole
infrastructure
around a system that like it could have
been
one button like it literally could have
and honestly
i personally think it would have been
better for the game if they were just
like you know what screw it it's one
button but you have to pay
every time and there's no way to earn it
in game like honestly if they did that i
would be like well
you know that's not really consumer
friendly but at least it's
straightforward and
it doesn't affect gameplay right like if
you want to pay a few extra bucks just
to make your guardian look cool whatever
as long as it's not like we're you pay
to win it's it's paid to look good fine
that would have been in my opinion
better than what's happening now
because now they're making it like the
ultra like it
it's just it appears like scummy and
like a weird freemium model where it's
like hey you can kind of do it
but not that much and there's constantly
that that tempt to like
now they have an incentive to introduce
as many armor sets as possible every
season because they've capped the amount
that you can get and it's just like
what like i yeah i mean i i could go on
but like that's my initial take was
before i even got to the other stuff i
was just
already like guys like it doesn't have
to be this complicated no wonder it took
them so long to work on this like
honestly they were out here coming up
okay what should the second
evolution of the synthetic currency be
called after synth strand then they get
synth weave
and then they turn that into a synth
horse that they ride over to the
store and then they pay their synth
bucks to get
it's just like in god's name were you
thinking dude
like it's i let's frame it let's frame
it before for the audio listeners those
people who may not know what's going
on you know let let's discuss let let me
read that let me get that back i got bad
guys gold
yeah which wherever you want to go man
the very first four steps
which literally stopped by poor boy thai
guy travis it is steps which is again
you get to 12 you get to this universal
ornament section you
you want to learn about transmog this is
the moment we've been waiting for
and like he said the first step before
we get too deep here before we get too
deep that's how i got
started here's a quick list of steps
that players will take to convert their
armored pairs into universes
there is like an oxymoron before we get
too deep
let's look at it before we get too deep
here's the three currencies we've
introduced to manage this one
thing that could have been one button it
was absolutely hilarious yeah defeat
enemies to earn sin for strand
step two to spend centistrand to
bounties
on bounties to earn cent the chord synth
chord
step three convert synth chord at the
loom in the tower i guess where eight is
gonna be
into synth weave step four use synth
weave to convert an
unlocked armor appearance legendary
quality or lore from collections
into universal armor ornaments so being
we're gonna stop right there real
quickly um
e i got to know how you felt because i
asked you yet when you just get to the
those initial steps those four steps of
transmog is what we've been waiting for
let's go
like i'm i'm so on board with travis i
was i read this
because basically i was talking to my
discord and i was like hey are you going
to do a twelve stream and i was like
maybe depending on you know got a
workout in usually it's been later in
the day
literally i think five minutes later it
drops i'm like okay let me read it and
see if i need to break this thing down
i get to this point first off i think we
already knew they were going to over
complicate it because i can't just call
it transmog they have to call it armor
synthesis
that alone is like do you have to make
something that everybody in
all of gaming knows this is what this is
well now it's armor synthesis what is it
transmog
it's actually shorter to say transmog
we've shortened it it's like
transmogrification is a long word
but it may as well be the same number of
syllables as armor synthesis so that
alone i'm like okay
that's fine then we get down here and
i'm like synth strand
synth chord synth weave
to you what what like that was exactly
what went through my mind i'm going okay
hold on so i can defeat enemies to earn
sent strand
question one how much can you hold how
often does it drop how much of a pain in
the blood is that going to be to grind
there's a few questions that go in there
spin synth strand on bounties i'm like
oh
we have bounties in the middle of this
process how much how many does it cost
is it one to one is it 500 to
like i don't know it might be 150 to 1
so again how fast does this stuff drop
then you go a little lower and you look
at the bounty so i'm like okay
so you're like crucible capture zones in
crucible just one example we'll go
through the rest of them in a minute i'm
like
okay is it 10 and it's a short boundary
is it like 200 this thing's gonna take
you a while
still don't know and then on top of that
then you after you finish your bounty
then you earn your synth cord
and that's not the thing you actually
use you have to take that back into the
tower i feel sorry for anybody on a
playstation
4 or an xbox one with any platter hard
drives
because you're gonna go in and out of
the tower to do all this stuff any more
than you already had to you have to go
to the loom
some people don't even know what a loom
is so go look that one up uh
in the tower to turn it into synth weave
and then
that's when you finally take that
currency into somewhere in the armor
system
to finally make your one piece an
ornament i'm going
i know the people who enjoy dress city
more than i do and i appreciate those
that do
cocktito is definitely one of them
tassie's definitely one of them he's got
the emblem
i'm sorry this is so so much more
convoluted complicated and unnecessary
for steps and the worst part was and
this is what
i don't normally reply to twabs normally
twitter is just like
you see them and i normally i'm like i
may say my video about it but i'm not
usually directly replying to bungie and
i was like
i'm usually quiet but i gotta say three
three currencies
a limitation which we'll get to in a bit
and then on top of that it's like all of
those things
or cash all of that combined is like
we've been waiting
better part of a decade to get this
system and this is how we get
what could as travis said be one button
or a simpler system
in multiple facets yeah it just hit me
all wrong
and i had i mean i was try i did a
fun thumbnail on my video i tried not to
go too hard in the clickbaity like
some of them but it was just like i
couldn't believe this is what we got
i really was floored i mean so that's
that's my kind of
overall reaction just even that section
what about you because i mean you kind
of went through the details
what was your top level like when you
got that far in
just pure comedy just pure comic i mean
it was just fun
i laughed i i chuckled you know just the
different terminologies of the word
synthesis
and you know the over complication for
no reason but the thing that i rolled my
eyes on which surprised me
was bounties because i was like why are
we
grinding for this like why is why unlike
other games that implement transmog
why you know it just it just felt so
forced engagement and i'm just like
are we that desperate for the content
you know for to keep the players in
and that it just got my mind thinking as
to the mindset like you know how we want
to be that fly in the room right we want
to know
in the board's room what's the process
cause we're trying to be logical look
this is funny we're laughing
we're rolling our eyes but there's a
part of me that says okay in there in
these rooms
i want the spy camera in this room i
need high fidelity like like i need to
know everything
discussion right i need to go i need to
see that guy the guy that's pitching all
right so then we're going to get the
sent the chord
the strain the weave what does that
whiteboard look like
yes just a mess of different like synth
fiber
no synth weave who can
determine who came up with the verbiage
like that's the guy i want to know the
verbiage guy
and then the bounty guy and like yeah i
just want to see how it all came
together i
sometimes i know we joking but i like to
seriously know these things travis like
i need to know the process i think my
personal hell is i get hired by bungie
and my entire job is to name all the
cancers they introduce
i think like if i ever end up in like a
strange you know in between life and
death scenario
from a thousand bargain it'll be like me
and they'll be like
what should we call level two of the
currency
how many more do we have crazy you know
what i was thinking of too is like
think about how many currencies and
consumables we have to consider
just for armor there's three upgrade
materials
for armor right there's all the
ascendant stuff there's
shaders there's armor mods there's now
three synth currencies there's silver
and bright dust if you're acquiring
armor there's legendary shards if you're
taking armor from your collections and
glimmer that's like
12 currencies for one thing in destiny
one thing it's got like 24 currencies
like helping to govern it and
it like i complain about currencies in
destiny all the time it's kind of like
tongue-in-cheek it's because
because a lot of them are like defunct
currencies where it's like
how is this still in the game like one
of the things that always has cracked me
up is that like
now in destiny there's a legitimate
currency called chocolate strange coins
that is a edible fake version of an
old currency from destiny 1 that now is
no longer relevant
and all of the things involved in
strange coins are also irrelevant like
zur
and everything else so it's like a it's
like a play on a currency of a currency
a guy that nobody remembers and it's
just like it's
so insane to me that that's in the game
and like
like that stuff is funny for me it's
just like wow like currencies in this
game are
absolutely insane but imagine being
legitimately a day one player
you start on season 14 of destiny and
the first thing you do is you go okay
well let's learn all the currencies and
as you're killing things you're getting
the synth dropping automatically
and you're starting to like figure out
how to spend it and like my brain would
just explode you ever
you ever hear that an mmo is really cool
and then you log on and it's so
complicated that you're just like all
right excuse
like this is way too much work like that
happened to me with like warframe the
first time i tried it like i heard that
i've heard it's crazy great and then i
logged on and i was just like dude i'd
like i don't have time to create an
encyclopedia off of this [ __ ] like
it's like and i just sort of sorry
uh but yeah
like if you were actually logging on day
one you would be completely lost because
you click y on armor and i don't know
how they're gonna
show like the whole like armor synthesis
in there but if it's in menu or you're
like
you have two screens just governing the
armor and maybe now it's a third one
to do synthesis i don't really know how
they plan on implementing it but like
the whole system is crazy and we haven't
even gotten into shaders and that's
another
currency it's kind of like a currency
it's an unlockable for
armor but at this point it's like mods
shaders
ascendant stuff to upgrade it uh
whatever those little
bricks are with the orange pips to
actually infuse
that's the other material that you have
to use like i don't even remember the
names
and people like bag on me in when i'm on
fire team chat for being like oh my god
he didn't know the name of the gun or
the currency he's like
how could you at this point like
i i remember everything that's ever
happened in any star wars canon
and like you know memorized like 40 halo
books and i can't remember the names of
the currencies of destiny
or any of the guns in the game so like
you know it's not my fault at this point
at this point like bungie needs to
control
their landscape and sorry i i could keep
going oh you're not a brother i mean
it's it's literally you know that's a
lot of things i was thinking about
and i was thinking also from an
inventory standpoint when you have so
many
because again i got so many of those
defunct currencies
and i'm like don't even use and it just
takes up that that block space
and then you get into these weird
situations where if they keep adding
more then you know you're gonna
hopefully not get locked out but that
was my initial
impressions of what the thought process
was
on those four steps of
them explaining to us what armor
synthesis tends to be
so yeah yeah that was we go get em no
we're gonna keep going
so they said to start so they gave you
kind of some details they say
you're gonna start earning cent strand
when defeating enemies in destiny 2.
i wonder how long it's going to draw
like what's the drop rate is this just
are you constantly going to be seeing
this on your screen now is this just
like
a forever drop after earning 150 cent
strand
we don't know what the capacity is on
that by the way watch it be 150.
you can only buy one at a time
players may visit 801 in the tower to
acquire class specific bounties which
reward
synth chord when developing this feature
way too much oh yeah like there's
development resources but i feel like
these were a bit squandered a little bit
um an early goal was to ensure players
could earn synthwave through
numerous activities in destiny 2. that
way players who spend most of their time
in the crucible could continue to do so
and still engage with armor synthesis
aren't you happy travis
all the crucible players still get to
earn their scent weave
there will be five categories of armor
synthesis bounties count them
five vanguard crucible gambit
destinations
or raids and dungeons here are some
examples
vanguard complete playlist strikes using
specific subclasses
accumulate points and nightfall strikes
can't deal with what is what is
happening to me
crucible capture zones in control
matches
complete crucible matches and defeat
opponents using specific damage types
as a team gambit send and defeat
blockers in gambit
defeat primeval envoys high value
targets and primevals in gambit
destinations defeat nightmares that
thing from like two years old that's
still hanging on
on any destination or in nightmare hunts
because those still need relevancy
defeat bosses while defeating the blind
well another two-year-old
three-year-old activity i'm sorry within
the dreaming city we lost travis
raids and dungeons complete the final
encounter on any raid or dungeon how
many people are going to be trading
checkpoints
for like prophecy uh generate orbs of
power in raids or dungeons if you pick
up the wrong bounty
don't worry some sense strands will be
refunded if you choose to abandon it but
not the full amount
so think carefully before abandoning
how was the reading how did we do what
is the opposite of mcclunky
you can change two letters from a funky
[Laughter]
i uh so how these bounties sounded
excellent right
high quality i guess this is the model
for destiny now is anytime there's an
event or
activity that they want us to do they
drive us back to the same pillars
of destiny that they do for everything
else it's the same with guardian games
or you're like oh what are you doing in
guardian games you strike something
unique or is it like a new event or are
they adding like interesting objectives
for you to accomplish
no go do strikes and go do
crucible and go do gambit the only
things that we have in our game and
like it's crazy because their life team
has gone
has come so far and they clearly have
like a lot of
resources and i mean just look at how
much they add in eververse for every
season every event and you'll know like
okay there's clearly people who are
focused on this
but but when i think of like the very
first live event they ever did
which was festival of the lost destiny
1.
even for that one they didn't really
have a lot to work with but they
clearly put time into decorating the
tower and then they had these little
activities you had to do within the
activities that were unique they didn't
add any unique activities but they had
like
you know a thing where i think you had
to jump off the map
in uh in a vault of glass or something
like that while dressed as
uh atheon like that was like one of the
one of the objectives and if you did
that
then you you completed a bounty but they
had like little clever ways of going hey
go out to these beloved events and like
do something interesting there
to complete this thing and even that is
gone now it's just like
go go and just do strikes again man like
yeah now we now we added a playlist
where everyone's a titan so
it'll just be a lot of punching like
that that's really like to me minimal
effort and this is like the same thing
it's
hey go do crucible go complete bounties
go
do all the stuff you're already doing in
the game and they're giving you more
reasons to do it but now there's also
more to think about
there's more to managing your inventory
there's more times you have to go back
to the tower and go and trade materials
with some
you know dumb face on screen that's like
hey
you've got the little like things on the
side and i just i just
this game is becoming a monster and it's
crazy
philosophy-wise because when destiny 2
launched their whole point was we're
going to simplify things and we're going
to take out
the we're going to take out the culture
of like everyone having to log on every
single day to play destiny just to be
relevant and that was like their goal
and now they've backtracked from that
because of the community but like
the community's kind of to blame for
this because they were like
we want things to grind for we want more
reasons to log on and now
you got what you wanted oh yeah you know
it's like it's like one of those uh
things where like the devil you know you
get the monkey pie you get your wishes
yeah exactly terrible
uh trade-off and now we've got exactly
what we want for it there's a million
reasons to play destiny every day
there's a million things to grind for
but
at what cost right
yeah now you're just you're just gonna
be entering playlists to kill things
every season
just to get that armor synth
chord or whatever the whatever the wave
is the
the final form so it has to level up
twice
don't remind me
what about you are you gonna be jumping
in getting all these bounties totally
adding this to your grind of the daily
routine this sucks because you know i am
captain fashion you know what i'm saying
like i'm fully aware that's why i want
your take today
that's why it's important here i'd be
dying as well so
yeah it's like i love the fashion aspect
of destiny so much and then
it's just very specific uh bounties too
like very specific things you got to do
and
which i found very interesting and and
again you know
all i think about is fake engagement
that's all i think
i'm just like this is fake engagement
like we we have to do better you know at
the end of the day like
and you know i'm trying to be nice
obviously with resources we reach that
evil word that we always say here with
studios and
you know what teams are working on what
but it's just like
i'm gonna go in but it's like it's just
it just feels like a really
missed opportunity to to really do
something
simple nice and and not
complicated and again i just
don't understand the reasoning we've
already got so
much bounty fatigue and didn't they just
come out with a twab
prior it was like we're looking at that
with the bounties and the system
didn't we i felt like we just finished
talking about this yeah the recent trial
right yeah
i tweeted that too i was just like hey
what was bungie thinking like oh you
know what we need is we need
more currencies and brownies in our game
and it's just like dude
you you like got you spent all this time
like
helping get those things down you took
away mercury and mars and
so we could have less in the game and
fewer currencies and now it's
it yeah it just boggles my mind man i
can't believe it
so like i said as we will dive deeper i
don't get to you but it's like
well i'm gonna have some more thoughts
as we get into it but yeah it's just
again i i just looked at it and the
engagement thing the body thing
really bothered me so e on this portion
before we get even deeper with this
where are you at with grinding getting
your bounties up
going to see ada running that control
capture point
um well for one you're gonna have people
abusing checkpoints for this
yeah that's gonna be ones who's got my
checkpoints i can knock you out my
people
actually grind for this i hope not
because you know what you might be able
to passively accomplish
while you're playing music i mean that
could be part of it i guess part of me
is we only know half the story here
because we only know
vagaries of the details we don't know
the details of how much
things are going to cost how much since
crap i can't even remember this is five
minutes ago
so how much do i need to go into the
world that gets sent strands so i need
to go into strikes and get since grand
to come back and buy a boundary to go
back into a strike
so i can work on earning my synth chord
and then that synth chord i turn that it
i think that's right
and it's i think i'm having a brain
tumor just manifest itself
i may have just had an aneurysm so leave
me stop
saying their names
since horde is like voldemort we it
shall not be
you can't use the word synth on this
podcast from this point forward
so i've gotta earn stuff in basic
activities to buy the bounties
to then go do those bounties to get
other
stuff so then i can so then i can go put
it into a loom
so the big question for me is how like
some of these are defeat the final you
know rate encounter that's checkpoints
right there but it's like capture zones
and crucibles like
is it going to be 50 or like a hundred
like a nightmare or like an iron banner
weekly thing
right or is it gonna be you know go get
five
zones and you're done then it's like why
am i even doing the first place so it's
like
either way i don't like to feel the
bounties if they're short or long
because
it's still just an arbitrary step when
you're gonna go make us go into these
activities to earn it in the first place
like you could take the bounties out and
be like
hey it costs like 500 cents strand to
buy one takes a little while to drop as
you go through doing activities you'll
still accumulate it from different
places
boss kills may give you a little bit
more raid bosses give you a little bit
more dungeons you know
trials will probably give you a little
bit more that type of stuff could be a
way to accumulate this
and then go buy europe like go buy your
ornament like that would be this
just take i've seen it to me like uh
shackle shotgun yesterday did it and i
forget somebody else they're like
here's the list and they literally just
like took you know
earned this and then they moved up the
bottom
the bottom line of like then go unlock
your ornament and just took out two and
three
just like earn this and unlock your
ornament the other two steps don't need
to be there
so it's just like two and three and
again for me
how long are these gonna be what is the
cost you always have to go back to the
tower for it you technically
buy it you can well you can use your
your phone app now so don't forget
get those phones i forget that party app
i have to do
i forget that's a thing honestly
probably not that
they might not because it requires a
specific material
because the other ones you just paid
glimmer for i don't know okay
good question that's a good question um
so yeah
mine's more at least with respect to the
bounties
i don't know how involved they're going
to be some seem just
go kill a boss or do certain things some
may be stupidly specific we'll see
but also how long that's the other
question so until i see that i don't
know if i'm going to love or hate him
but
it's just more bounties i mean i'm not
gonna love it yeah
just like i said it just feels like
they're they're at least the system
itself it feels just stuck in this
antiquated
thing of cycle of what we've been doing
for a while it just feels redundant
and they've applied it to a shader
system so it's just like that's why i
think the disgusting travis face is
where it's gonna be
because we've been as destiny players
we've been
doing this bounty stuff for so long and
they they've got to figure out
a new mechanic or just eliminate steps
and make things simpler another thing
the community asked for
bounties remember when destiny 2 vanilla
launched and they removed the bounties
and everybody was like where's their
mannys and i was like guys
you do not want bounties like that was
like i was like what
why are people asking for bounties
because there were those weekly
challenges that appeared on the side
it's like okay you can passively
accomplish those but it's not a huge
part
ever since they've added bounties it's
just been like a proliferation they're
like let's go for it let's like give
them a million bounties to do and i'm
just like oh no
like this isn't what i wanted guys i
often disagree with the community when
they ask to like make things more
complicated
or especially like to give us things to
grind for i'm always like oh my god like
please no i have other games to play
like i got stuff to do guys but you know
in this one i was just like as soon as
bounds were added i was like
this is not going to end well and here
we are all these years later
hey at least we know what the soundtrack
for season 14 is going to be like though
really heavy on synth
that's a good one right there
yeah so what else is going on with the
business
i would say is the cherry but possibly
the turd on top
um players may earn up to 10 synthwave
per class per season
except in season of the redacted to
celebrate the introduction of armor
synthesis i'm just going to start saying
transmog
in season of the redact in season of
redacted not even the
players may earn 10 additional synthwave
for the introductory experience in total
during season of redacted players may
earn up to 20 century per class
which can either be used to convert four
full sets of armor or
20 specific items for example hunters
could have four pieces of armor
and 16 cloaks if they choose so
the big explosion seems to be mo
vastly weighing in this being the issue
they cap it at 10 per season basically
two armor sets
how many armor sets do we get per season
usually more than two
yeah use one too yeah so then you are
almost always more than two
i mean one of them you acquire through
every verse but yeah yeah so then
theoretically you will always be behind
right could this is like a completionist
nightmare if they don't have deep
pockets
you're gonna have to pay like the
completionists are just going to have to
annie up and paul tassie rip your wallet
but i know you'll be in there oh yeah
he's going to be one of those whales and
bungee's like oh come on tessie let's
open that check
just read us 10 grand just get it over
with just be done yeah
so thoughts on these seasonal limits
gentlemen whoever wants to take this one
first go nuts
travis it's a nightmare it's like
it's the worst of both worlds it's
you know what this reminds me of it
reminds me of when they implemented the
collection system and then they were
like oh but no random world weapons
they're
included it's like it's like the same
thing it's like the
the thing that we wanted they
implemented
and then it somehow implemented it
without accomplishing the thing that it
was supposed to do
yep like the whole point of the
collection system was i want every item
i have to be
safe and for me to pull it out of my
vault anytime i want and it
it effectively is a place i go to grab
an exotic that i deleted a couple
seasons ago every once in a while i
never go to my collection system really
ever
unless i'm wondering if i'm missing a
shader or an emote or something but
it's not a place that any of us spend a
lot of time and
now they've managed to implement an
armor synthesis
transmog system that doesn't actually
let you
have freedom with what your armor is it
lets you do it two at a time or
oh because they're nice next season we
get to do four and one
oh there you go it's it's it
it is it's lunacy and also
this is kind of a weird pet peeve but
isn't it ten pieces of armor which means
oh so it is a full two armor sets yep
right
oh my god yeah but imagine if you
imagine if you don't do like it's you
have to do two armor sets because if you
did like
if you were like a hunter and you
decided to spend like five of your armor
pieces on capes
or or whatever then you have like an odd
amount and you can't do a full armor set
you know you're like
then the next season you're like oh i'll
use i'll use four and then you get there
and you're like oh i don't have enough
for
the full armor set and you know that
there's that whole thing
i mean like like obviously what they're
trying to do is get you to just buy it
yeah clearly i get that
but i honestly i think i would have
rather had to pay for every armor set
exclusively
just like if you want to do this if you
want this feature you have to pay real
world money
i would prefer that just to cut down on
the bloat to the game
the three currencies the bounties the
confusion of like like like like evonda
said like i'm worried about how often
i'm gonna see the word
synth strand on my screen how many times
is that going to pop up as like a drop
you know every 150 kills i'm gonna see
it that's like water torture
like it when is the synth strand gonna
appear on screen and then you kill a
fallen
you know vandal it's like and it drops
down in the corner and i'm just like no
stop but wait this game doesn't have
auto loot so you're gonna have to go run
and pick that up off the ground
[Laughter]
that hopefully they don't apply the
laurel system
with this that's the last thing we need
to be doing to get
your synthetic whatever roll down the
cliff oh yeah you get it
and you
the day i find myself running around in
destiny trying to chase down a
synth strand that's rolling away from me
is the day i just get up and walk into
the ocean
hey at least you're closer to it than i
am so
yo i feel your man yeah okay this is
yeah this this is this is something um i
don't even know even
again this was just one of those things
i was just you know very
i was just it was just i was surprised
how brazen they were
like this is pretty brazen you know to
do this and
again trying to be fair trying to
understand and
and it it clearly the cap is to get us
to see
tests and it's just like yeah that's it
all right
and you know it just you know what it
look they're they're they're on their
own we get it
you know finances you know games cost
we get it you know but um i guess
because
you know what it is it hurts because we
waited
so long we waited so long
we're working on it and this was like
the last thing
we thought they would do or mess up like
because we
waited so long because it could have
been one button
one button
and it was like it kind of reminds me it
has some
eerie similarities to how when i wait we
waited for trials and it was like okay
we're gonna we're gonna make a look at
it and we're gonna make it better than
before
and you know the old like that if it
wasn't broke don't fix it thing and i'm
just like
why is this so complicated like again
like you said travis like
one button you know why why are we doing
this so
again you know
to me it just screams
finances finances finances and
this is not going to go well this is not
going to go up the question is going to
be
you know how what it seems like the
community's pushing back
very hard already right very hard so
how dug in are they i want to know
that's the question to me
because at the end of the day people are
flipping you know i'm saying like
tassie's out here
everybody's out here as he was gonna
like revolt and throw his
dress in the emblem off the tower like
that was an epic tweet
that was that was happening and i i get
it you know and holly was making it you
know he's being fair he's like how many
armor ornaments does everyone use and i
understand your sentiment brother i do
but
the the question becomes why the cap if
if someone wants to live in this game
and truly grind
every bounty of synth or whatever right
and they want to
live in it why can't they just live in
it and just do it like similar to
how bright dust is implemented like
there's those bounties for bright dust
you kind of keep going for the most part
and it's just one of those things so
it it just doesn't feel good it doesn't
hurt
yeah sorry i didn't want to interrupt
you but i was like i just had one in my
head
and that's a fair question is like
there's some people who will say
hey how many does the average person use
right it may or may not be that
many but when the system comes out in
this fashion
there's a lot of people that will just
straight up disengage period
because of how limiting it is if you're
going to give like the average person be
like hey you can grind this stuff out
and be like
how's that new player experience well if
i do this
i can slowly unlock more and more things
and i can do this and this is just
something cool that i can add to my
grind
because it's a simple process if it was
and
i could add these you know as i keep
doing these new activities i can add
this armor to my repertoire of things
that i can put on
on the other side now you limit it you
cap it hard and you want it's like some
people are gonna grind so much and be
like
okay i'm done i got these last like four
or five sets dude i've put so many hours
in this game i'm to drop like the 30
bucks at this point i don't want to
spend a dollar
right because of how to me egregious it
is
limiting and shoving you towards the
eververse if you wanted to grind
and this season may be a little better
because you get four sets but next
season
or the season if it truly stays at two
right
like there's people who have don't even
wait till we get to the limitations
that's a whole fun part as well
um but it's to me the limitation is
if the limit was like hey you could do
like 10 sets a season somebody's like
that's probably a decent grind that's
that would feel a little it's
two it's small it's so small for as many
as there are
that's the thing it's either you're
gonna knock it out you're like oh my
first week
well i can't get any more armor synth
i'm done with that this season like the
fact that it can end that quickly
depending on how long the grind is of
course we don't know but
the fact that that's one more thing that
could extend the life of your game like
tazzy said it pretty well and it's like
what are the things he didn't want to
see
basically everything on the swab but
then the other piece is if you limit it
then you like what are those gaps when
you have
before guardian games as the story wraps
up if they're like
a little early season centric towards
the story that gap
between the beginning and the end this
is when you could like you know i got a
couple armor sets i could grind those
out it'd be the perfect time for that
and now by your natural playing in the
early part you probably already maxed
out what you can for the season
again less reason to log into the game
they're limiting themselves
and again pushing you even harder in so
it's like whether it's how many i have
or how many i do or don't want there's a
decent amount that are out there
and if i wanted to go after more i can't
if i'm forced to pay some people can't
some people's wallets can but if you
vote with your wallet
then i'm just angry at the system so
it's like that's where it hurts to me is
because
they push you so far in that direction
i'm gonna not do it out of spite
and that's just me gotta break i gotta
bring it back
can't wait for the teddies of the world
oh
i hope they make a triumph that's like
you know armor synthesized
three armor sets this season you know
and i hope teddy just i hope i hope he
feels the hurt that completionist
the completion is in him yeah oh yeah
yeah it's just gonna be the worst
so the question i i bring it back to you
two gents
how long do you think
they stay dug in or do they not relent
do they
hold the line against the community
this is the like million dollar question
and i think
it's impossible to predict because
bungie has in the past
stuck to their guns to their dying
breath on something nobody liked
and given up on things that seemed like
huge things
at the drop of a hat so like like
you know random rolls on guns and uh
their
their sun setting like they that was
their most recent flip-flop that i could
not believe was happening so soon
um so i think there's a way
where
this seems to me almost like a change in
their model
like their plan is going forward that
destiny's gonna be like a free-to-play
game
like warframe where maybe there is no
seasonal cost
if that happens and they change and they
say hey going forward
all of our seasons are free but we're
now more of a freemium model eververse
has a larger presence
uh there's certain things you can't earn
or be a completionist without
paying for then i think fans are
less crazy about it but the fact that
this is a paid
game i'm paying every season i'm paying
every expansion
and i'm being treated like i'm on
fortnight logging on without an xbox
live
subscription like it's it's crazy like
who do you think you are i i
i didn't download it sorry is destiny
being made by zynga now like what the
hell is this
so it's just if they if they change
their model and they just go you know
screw it we're on game pass
we're you know free to play we're we're
not gonna charge you for anything and
this is our new model
i think they can stick to their guns and
maybe that's the plan
maybe we're seeing maybe we're seeing
this in a terrible light because we
still view destiny
as a premium game and not as like a
warframe
or a call of duty war zone and maybe
that's not what their
maybe their eyes are a few steps ahead
of ours in which case
i could see them sticking to their guns
forever but
if it's typical bungie and they just did
this because they felt like it and
didn't think it through and they're
going to flip-flop
on it and like maybe before the system
even launches
uh i could also see that so i i don't
think there's really a way to predict it
i think you kind of have to know like
where is bungie's head is this a
strategic shift
because they're they're thinking of
changing the way that destiny
works and their their model or is this
just something that they completely
bungled
or bungeed as i call it when they do it
i was like i heard
one and this is one i would hope isn't
true
but if you take the whales you roll it
out in season 14
let them dump as much as they're going
to in season 14 to unlock these
and then fix it in 15. right and give
that
one see and you want to talk about some
pissed-off people then be like
well now in going into season 15 we've
ironed out some technical difficulties
with these year one ornaments so we're
unlocking more
now you can do 10 per season or
something instead of two so somebody
didn't have to buy
you know 20 ornaments or something like
that that seems
really really bad and if something like
that was actually ever planned
that would honestly make bungie a pretty
sleazy developer so i would never see
that as intentional
that's one of those where sometimes you
read between the lines and you're like
man that timing seems convenient
again that's stuff you hope you never
see but on the other side
is as you said what
somewhere somebody had to be like hey
they do these like community feedback
things and they're all pumped and doing
the bungee fist pump tweets out tweet
outs and stuff
they're excited about a future did they
like put
feelers out on this to say hey how is
this gonna go down do we ever expect
this
if they did that type of stuff which
they're very data driven and i can't
imagine their head is just in the sand
then it seems like a very intentional
decision which as you said then sees me
pointing them
towards eververse which kind of sucks
but they're also trying to understand
the business model side of it to where
hey we can give this to you but the
system took time to develop
right i know it's like i know they're a
business there is a huge business case
for why
this is this way i understand that but
personally as a player
it sucks just flat out to me it just is
a
not great system on many aspects and
that's the part for me that it's like
if they put themselves in the player's
shoes they're like hey a new person
like the newer player is gonna be even
harder pressed to see like
if they start keep the more they're
gonna start unlocking more and more
stuff if they go don't exactly know what
this is
well they won't know what it is so
complicated yeah well that's fair but
then as they start oh look at this cool
dungeon
here's this cool dungeon here's your
dreaming city set they still start going
doing all these activities well how many
can i have
two so like that's the stuff that will
sink into a new player later and that's
going to be it feels bad it feels bad
for us now because we're aware of it
the new player it's going to sink in
later and that's going to suck too so it
it hits in two different ways but it's
not good on either end
right yeah and my like question is like
either
i think they tried to accomplish two
things at once with the system
on one hand they're trying to make it an
engagement play where they're trying to
get those monthly active users up
because that's what every live service
cares about right
yeah with the with the like gamification
which they clearly tried
way too hard to gamify it with all the
currencies and like
the leveling up like like you're
training your charmander to a charizard
with a
synth you know like it's like this weird
like pokemon
evolution thing uh and then and then
on the other hand then they capped it
they go okay now we did our gamification
thing so we're gonna make sure they can
only do so much of that
and then the other half is monetization
and it's like those are both things we
know bungie cares about is like
gamifying and forcing people to log on
and grind for stuff and getting them in
the
the player in the game more and for
longer
so we know they care about that and then
they also care about their bottom line
and they're doing both of these things
and i think that if they would have just
picked one the system
like they would have gotten half as much
flack as they're getting now but the
fact that they tried to do both
they made this crazy convoluted in-game
gamification and tried to get the money
like pick one man
pick one either your goal is to get
people to play your game
as often as possible and you're gonna
make this really bonker system
to force us to play or you're going to
just make money off of it but like the
fact that they tried to do both and
it makes it seem like both failed and
they they didn't accomplish but we'll
see if
they they kind of didn't accomplish
their goal which is like
making it so that you can apply any look
to any armor which like
if you play diablo like it's one button
and you can do it with any armor and any
armor that you've acquired and instead
it's just
it's just this monster that doesn't even
accomplish the thing that we thought it
was going to accomplish
eg the collection system yeah yeah
so you said it said it good brother i
mean very
very interesting and and like i said i'm
just curious
to see if we get a sun setting reversal
at some point do we get a lightning
up on the cap do we get anything
with how crazy the community is because
it's it's it's they're not the
community's not not having none of this
but you know we're going to see how dug
in they
are and we still got what we got shaders
so in case it wasn't complicated enough
let me explain
the exceptions the caveats the asterisks
or the footnotes whatever you want to
call these
universe you little i can't talk that's
how fun this is
universal ornaments may only be applied
to legendary armor pieces
exotic armor pieces cannot take the
appearance of an alternate armor as we
want to maintain their appearance for
players to quickly identify and
understand
what exotic perks a player has a player
may have in all activities
you can put exotic ornaments on there
but they want you to be like
if you're running six coyote they want
to know this person is going to be
dodging like crazy
we get that that's kind of been a
general trend with exotics for pvp
mostly
bless you there will also be a few
exceptions at launch
for year one ornaments due to technical
constraints
again we see continue we there's this
trend of technical limitations when we
joke about this and wonder how long d2
is going to last
still a thing but we are working on
solutions for these exceptions
are as follows year one armor ornaments
vanguard crucible
iron banner faction rallies um
prestige raids trials of the nine you
can't tell me
like trials players would be like dude i
want to go flop my trials of the nine
stuff because nobody else has this stuff
yeah yeah i have it the prestige trades
the trial stuff
faction rallies so so where's the reason
for that i don't really technical
limitations
technical limitation constraints yeah
something with that
system looks like they like i said that
year one stuff
or whatever it doesn't play nice
technically yes
again that's where i wonder how weirdly
complicated every piece of gear we has
it have
is right but then they said below that
that you can apply it
yeah ornaments can still be applied if
bass if the bass armor piece is from
an activity that the ornament originates
so if it shows up as an armor ornament
though because like
i love the year one iron banner armor
from destiny 2 which is like the one
that makes you look like a samurai like
i rock that
all the time in crucible and i know it
only shows up as an ornament in my
ornament list if i'm
wearing an iron banner armor set so i
always make sure to go to my way and get
a good iron banner armor set because i
want to wear that
that armor but like if it's already in
your ornaments list
like this and believe me i read this
about four times and still was confused
ornaments can still be applied if the
base armor piece
from an activity that the ornament
originates
as an example if a player owns crucible
ornaments
cm why does that not make sense if a
player owns crucible ornaments from
cursive which i do they may be applied
to crucible armor pieces at no cost
however these ornaments cannot be
applied to seasonal armor
why what what so okay so if you have the
crucible armor
ornaments you can apply it to crucible
pieces but you can't apply the old
crucible armor ornaments to
basically anything else right it has to
be
locked into the activity it originated
with
yes so it's yeah it that seems databasey
it did yeah it was like some weird
tagging of inventory items
exactly yeah that's database that's some
technical
weird new yep additionally i'm sorry
oh we're just gonna try and cover all
this at once please please all base
armor appearances
from 20 all armor appearances from the
2018 and 2019 solstice of heroes events
will be available for armor synthesis
transmog should just say that however
due to an issue where 2018 and 2019
glows cannot be socketed alongside armor
appearances in the new guardian
appearance system
the glows will not be supported
hopefully you didn't grind those out
because you're not getting them
solstice 2020 armor were developed with
the guardian appearance system in mind
and players will retain the white armor
glows if it was earned during the event
subclass based glows will continue to
function on their universal ornaments as
well
there's a lot of caveats in here
this is my personal vietnam you're going
through it you're going through it right
there
yeah i mean kind of sucks man with the
um
the year one especially because we
waited so long you know and i i some of
those
like like travis said like charles at
the don that looks cool very unique you
can't get that set
you know anymore and faction rally i was
i was a huge
new monarchy fan with the shaders and
the stuff that they got going on there
and it kind of hurts a little bit as
well too so it's just like
vanguard is probably the only thing i
don't remember i'd always thought the
vanguard stuff was ugly that's just me
so i yeah yeah okay okay i was just like
that one but
yeah it's just you know here we go and
then like he was saying with with the
glows
you know with the um sources of hero
stuff and that stuff
was extremely grindy yeah but you had to
master work that stuff and all those
pieces
so it's a shame i'm trying to be nice
here with technical difficulties and and
database stuff i i'm trying to be
respectful here
but i i do remember you know i mean that
that solstice stuff was kind of cool man
like i wanted to rock that and get the
little flames going and the
matching and stuff so yeah no
not getting it and uh yeah so wait what
you dig
[Applause]
it's the collection system again man we
just have all these systems that like
like what if i told you that we would
have
transmog but it wouldn't affect all of
your armor sets what if i told you
that you could have a collection system
but you can't pull out any randomized
weapons and it's just like
what what is this bizarre like devil's
bargain i keep making with destiny where
they keep asking
for something and they they offer me
it's like oh you can be the prettiest
woman in the world but you'll smell like
yeah
you know like it's like this floor it's
like a floor yeah
all the time
but you have to drive around in a pinto
for the rest of your life like yeah
exactly like it's like these strange
like what-if scenarios where i'm just
like
i just want the thing like just give me
the thing i want please
hey like you know i buy your game but
no i it's it's it's it's super
disappointing on top of like a system
that's already
designed to be disappointing i mean
let's be honest that's it is
literally designed to disappoint you
it's like hey do you want to do armor
synthesis
well here's a three-step process with
three separate types of currencies that
you have to upgrade
and by the way once you figure out the
damn system you're already done because
you can only do two a season
it's like and then and then and then all
of that stuff
and it doesn't do the full thing that
you want it to do anyway
on top of that like it's it's designed
to disappoint you
so that you'll pay money and then even
when you pay money
i still can't no you've stuck
it's just killing me man it's really
killing me i i
there there has to be i always say this
and i'm
always disappointed let's go but there
has to be something we don't know about
that bungie is planning there has to be
an announcement around the corner where
they're like we're going full free to
play
it's just a freemium model now you don't
have to pay for seasons there has to be
something like that otherwise
nothing they're doing makes sense
that's that's all i've got man like it's
kind of like those
you know the leap of faith believe in
bungie sort of thing which i think lots
of people
in the bungie in the destiny community
drink the kool-aid myself included where
i'm just like
this game i know they've got a plan like
there's something going on that they
figured out
and often we're just wrong and they're
you know like
like i just for me for example
weapon sunsetting when they said weapon
sunsetting was a thing
there were those of us in the community
myself paul tassie others
who said believe in bungie they gotta
have a plan here they wouldn't just be
telling us weapons sun setting unless
they were gonna try some crazy stuff
where every season the sandbox was going
to be crazy and dynamic and they were
going to
try new things and then it it just
didn't happen and the only guy who saw
it
coming was the most pessimistic dude
ever destin
who was like there's no way they have a
plan and he was right
and i'm you know i'll be on fire team
chat later today shameless plug
if you guys watch that and i'm sure he's
going to have a pessimistic take on this
but oh my god
dustin on this one that's going to be an
amazing just like
dumpster fire of a tape that's it's
going to be awesome
there has to be a plan or
there isn't a plan and i'm just
i'm appalled like i'm i just have no
words beyond the million words that i've
just
exploded out of my mouth but i have no
words but these words
but these ones i have no words but with
that said here are a few thoughts whips
out manifesto
i'm gonna go ahead and read you my
dissertation over why this is a bad idea
um yeah and we haven't even got to the
best part
we'll also offer synthwave templates
for direct purchase through the guardian
appearance screen
you don't have to sorry did did you say
synthwaid templates is that a fourth
currency
yes
did you say something did you
did you say synthwai
are you go jeff get him jim
and synthwave template bundles because
you need
more of them you can buy them in packs
packs of five
i love this how you do hold on you don't
even have to buy them
through ever store they're straight in
that guardian appearance screen they're
making it
so easy just right here you can get
those
those those silver right here you you
got any more of those you got more of
those photos
since strands synth chords synth weave
simply templates simple weave
bundles i feel like
i can't remember the kill
queen bundles
we i feel like i feel like at this point
it's like a movie quote and i can't
remember a tv show it's like scentweave
scent weave right
now
facts oh man
literally watching my my guest break
down live
in front of us the decomposition is
happening as we speak
it's one of those things where just when
i think i've accepted my disappointment
it bubbles up
it bubbles up like my disappointing
child who went into you know painting or
something it's just like
i want to accept who you are and then he
goes here here's my newest doodle and
i'm just like yeah
save centuries say synth we've one more
goddamn time yeah
oh to avoid mistaken purchases synthwave
templates from eververse can be applied
to all classes
about right there the fact that you can
only get 10 per class what if it was
just 30 per account
i mostly play my titan i don't usually
play the other two because
i haven't been a three class player in a
while what if it was just like
so many per season per a general account
that would lighten this load a little
bit but again
now they're limiting the single player
per single character player
and giving that three person but again
nobody plays
every character evenly even at least the
season some people hey i played my
warlock this season then it was hunter
this season
and they do that kind of flip and you
can at least lean heavy into one
nope gotta play them all even
yeah you know what's hilarious and
really
overlooked if you think about it let's
get it let's get it is
synth is actually a word for like
artificial
and everything about the system is
artificial the grind
the grind is artificial the amount of
currencies
artificially decided and evolved
and the the system of the limits are
artificially implemented
everything about this is so aptly
synthetic that they've named the entire
thing
themed yes
i think frankly bungie doesn't get
enough credit for that they don't get in
there
they don't their wordplay is really
incredibly on the nose
yeah they spit in bars right there
that's what we call it well let's talk
shaders
the guardian appearance before we get
into
this question do we think there's going
to be a limit cap
on the templates no zero
they'll probably be three levels of
bundles they'll be synth weave bundle
bronze
synth weave bundle silver and the bundle
please lube up
yeah yeah and if you if you
uh if you sent this if you if you
transmog an armor set
through the free model and not through
pang it'll have like a
a non-premium watermark yo you're stupid
the synthwave templates come with a
bonus glow
or like a bonus like exotic like fashion
piece like the gauntlets
all have um hawthorne's bird on your
shoulder if you pay for it
twitchy if you if you do the freemium
armor synthesis
you can only use the blue shaders with
like the
that combo change by the way can zavala
switch colors like
blue and orange it's just not my jam god
every i'm like
no just no no every time no yeah
blue and orange are like two colors that
like i think
like officially don't go together like
i should and i had a blue tie and an
orange shirt you'd be like travis did
you have a
seizure this morning or you're in a
dress like what happened
you know did you did you get dressed in
the dark what you doing
the vanguard armor looks like a guardian
like that that cartoon bit
well as a broncos fan you know you know
oh that's it we finally got it is from
denver we finally figured it out
thank you irl type last city's endeavor
oh
it's like that it's like that joke or a
cartoon character runs through a
wardrobe and then when they come out on
the other side they're wearing like
you know the the random clothes that
they ran that's what you get when you
get the vanguard blow it away ass do you
smell
burnt toast this morning
yeah yeah so let's talk shaders oh yeah
shaders hold on stage two
this one gets me into more technical
limitations because it's gotta be
through the guardian appearance screen
we took an opportunity to improve the
shader experience currently
shaders are a one-time use consumable
that must be repurchased from
collections for glimmer
or legendary shards starting next season
all
unlocked shaders will be visible on the
guardian appearance screen when hovering
over the shader bucket
players must apply shaders for 500
glimmer
per piece of armor additionally we've
added the request to apply all which
will cost
2500 there's not even a damn discount
this is the same glimmer cost to
purchase the shaders now but we've done
away with the legendary shard
requirements
okay i want to stop right there and go
why the hell does it still cost glimmer
and if the only thing i can think of the
only thing is that is so
buried in the code that applying a
shader has to be some transactional
system thing
right that is the only thing i can think
of because otherwise
it should be zero zero cause it's just
like
i mean no offense but anthem i could
paint the living crap out of my arm or
an anthem no matter what color i want
just
click try material color didn't matter
didn't cost me a damn thing
this it's still glimmer why yeah
why and then we still have a glimmer cap
but yeah this has to be attacked the
only thing in my mind that i can come up
with it is a technical
transaction in the system to apply this
this has to happen
otherwise it makes no sense no way i
mean like
it's been in the syst it's been in it
since d2 though it's been in since
launch that's the it's been in the
system because they want you to spend
because that's the loop
that's how they get you it's crazy to me
let's just say i hope that's it i hope i
hope you're right
i hope it is a technical limitation
although that does seem to be their
go-to
they go yeah technical limitation we
can't do it it's not on us
you're just gonna have to pay money just
by it by
accident oh in season season 15
technically
season 15 we've unlocked 20 more armor
sets there's
yes yes you know what's crazy is i've
never heard of a
technical limitation to eververse due to
technical limitations
we can only charge you so much uh
[Laughter]
i can only buy it in 50 packs at a time
hey let me tell you they should just
move the collection system over to
eververse because there's no technical
limitations
on that system clean like
extraordinary performance no issues
ever versus windows 10 release
like you know four point two five and
two
your collection system is back in
windows 95 or something yeah
yeah even on the xbox one days it was
hilarious you press start to load your
character screen
and you see that white screen for a
little bit before your character comes
up you ever click on the buy
silver button and see how fast it's like
[Music]
but you know it's crazy to me that like
a currency
you pay for which let's be honest up
until now
shaders are a currency you earn them you
get stacks of them or you buy them you
have to pay other materials
and then let's say you went and you
purchased
a a shader from eververse and then when
you go to apply it
it charges you your guardian in-game
its own money to do it so it's like
it's like it's like you know you pay but
i've already paid and then you know the
the faustian bargain again the witch in
her cauldron is like
but now you must pay the in-game
currency to apply
the thing that you've paid in real life
and it's just like
what actually is happening but it's yeah
anyway
uh the the that that whole system has
boggled my mind and i hope you're right
that it is a technical
limitation but no way dude no
way because if it was they could charge
you one glimmer and then it would never
be a problem everything could cost one
glimmer it's still a transaction right
what is happening to my life on the
bright side we gotta apply all
yay i was like again it's like oh forget
we feel like we had somebody on recently
it's like a little
one two steps forward one step back this
is just like right now we're just doing
a tango back and forth this is one to
one because you're like hey they're no
longer consumable
still got to pay for them no and it's
nice if the interface looked nice
at least you know you got you can hover
you can see all of them now i mean
honestly like the system itself the look
of the appearance screen i'm not going
to argue it looks like it should be
you know well received they apply shader
to everything you can mix and match look
through your armor
the the system itself does not look bad
it looks like they actually implemented
it well
a plial is a good function technical
limitation aside of the glimmer it's
like 500 glimmers usually not that much
why we have a cap i don't know but all
of those things is like that's fine
it still hurts and we got one other
shaders will continue to be earned
through various activities so you're
still going to be unlocking them from
places
or it can be purchased using bright dust
or silver from the eververse store
with the update to shaders we'll be
increasing their cost from 40
to 300 bright dust so that is why
30 repeatable boundaries
that bothered me okay so that one
actually makes sense to me break it down
take me well off the cliff for this
until up until now they were consumables
and you had to pay for them a bunch of
times up to five times if you wanted to
apply them to
an entire armor set now you pay once so
it has to cost more
because you pay once and it unlocks for
good
now is it a good look to increase the
cost of shader 680
at the same time you're introducing all
of these other
ways to make us pay absolutely not but
does it make
sense mechanically yes i will defend
bungie
in this case because it is now a
permanent unlock you're getting a
one-time transaction they're not
counting on you
paying five times for one shader just to
apply it to an armor set so
that makes sense to me all right i'm
waiting
early terrible
hey can we take this one thing like give
them just a little bit
like hey by the way these things are
still going to be the same we didn't we
didn't hit you here no we hit you here
too okay
like it's like blow after blow after
blow like again
i need to know who's in the room saying
what to who
and how they're saying it and how
they're going to sell this to us like
how what was the approach like this is
just
wow like like really this is what we do
again technically i get what you're
saying
but you just told us we got a cap you
just told us you know
all these limits and now we get to send
the template from
tess eververse and you're basically
forcing us in that direction if we want
unlimited customization and it's just
like
read the room who they're not
reading it and it just it's just weirdly
tone deaf like just out of control and
especially
for the weight we waited so long
like press x to do it like why is all
of this extra
the crazy thing is how much they love to
make us hold the x button in this game
and the answer was right in front of
them all along for transmog and they
missed it
you know how long i had to hold x this
week to delete all my shaders oh i've
got one
upon request i haven't even done it all
i haven't even done i did it
i did the i went to you know lord
kryptark what's his face royal
yeah and and just well the best
kryptonites i've never known by name
of their deeds uh so i don't know his
name i i
was like dm in here just killing it
yes yes uh he uh yeah so
i went to him and i just deleted it and
while i was holding x i thought
i hope this is how transmog works i hope
i could just hold
x to apply something like you do with
everything else in the game
but now i'm going to be grinding for
sith strands strands cords or weaves
you know what i love bubbles you know
what you're doing or bubbles
you know what you're doing this is my
favorite what about those templates
yeah my favorite sentence is and there
you have it
we're excited
for the addition of arma synthesis
who wrote this one this is dng right the
dmg right yeah
no like i give dmg props like he's
there's i mean no offense to the
community guys they are taking just a
[ __ ] storm right now and i'll just flat
up say it because yeah
they it is all flying at them and he's
just holding up the right messenger he's
the messenger
that's just shooting the messenger at
that point and that's why you're like
what
meeting rooms levels of people did all
of this go through
to get what we get here in this swab
how how many pieces
i would love to know the thought process
the discussions to see where it landed
the finance guy walks in and says all
this other stuff
and here's the balancing act but these
people are going to be mad who
the entire player base is going to be
pissed but we got to make money
we got a whole studio to open and we got
to pay for you know
2 000 more people that we're gonna hire
and we're gonna pay for it somehow and
people been asking for this one thing
for seven years so we're going to make
bank off of it
yeah it's probably they say
i like this system you have you guys
heard anybody in the system in the
community who likes it
i heard one per i had no even like
fallout and cool guy i want a name
like literally fallout cool guy
literally disagreed on twitter over the
same thing and those guys are just gross
so oh okay okay so all that was against
cool guy was like
just basically fine with it and then you
can take the piece you can probably make
the argument of
how many people really care about that
many ornaments and all those things and
is this really going to be something
that everybody explodes about or
whatever
i get that side of it i truly do get
that like hey i've only got like you
know i'm
a casual player i got a couple sets you
know this seems like four is going to be
fine
i'll work on my other armor ornaments
from everest that i unlock from the
season pass anyway
you know it's a good mix keeps me going
i don't really care
i can see that person in that side of
the argument where depending
and this is again where i feel bungie
looked at the data
and said how much is the average
person the casual who doesn't listen to
podcasts look at youtube videos who just
logs in my play for free
looks at this system and says hey four
sets not too shabby i got a couple old
sets stored up they
may see that like 70 percent of their
player base is going to do this but on
the other side you have to
have to remember that like your most
dedicated people who have been at this
this game alone for seven years but they
wanted or for four years
but they wanted it three years before
that in the previous game
to do all of this to that group of
people that have still been keeping your
game alive
posting the videos having something to
watch on twitch that you still play
through
all of those pieces still need to be an
account and again i this leans so heavy
into the business decision
as opposed to doing a quality of life
thing
for the player base and that's where
it falls like some people it's like
outriders doesn't have a whole lot of
transmog
in there but you know what i'm having a
blast right now this is coming at a time
and we even got to guardian games yet
right this is coming at a time where
it's like the stories are really cool
but the gameplay is just
dragging through the same playlists and
the same repetition of bounties and
strikes and gambit
crucible and bounties and strikes and
gimmick crucible and i'm about to walk
out of the room like travis did
i haven't yet but that's like that's
where some people have been in this for
so long and those
like long-term players this hits them
hard
and i think that's the p that's why i
tweeted i was just like
after more the better part of a decade
this just doesn't feel right please
reconsider
that's what i said yeah no i agree and i
think
my my biggest thing was gonna be if i
had
of all the egregiousness if i had to
rank
you know it's definitely the cap because
you know for me it's like okay let your
most
dedicated players grind to their hearts
content if they want to do it
let them let them have that you know
what i'm saying it's just again to limit
it's purely financial and then then it
comes down to okay what's the reasoning
you know
and if the reasoning is that and i get i
guess the reason why
it really bothers me with the financial
reasons because we just came off of the
bungee tweaks and success
and we just they painted this picture
that the future is so bright
but this look like your pockets is light
this look like this don't match your
future and there's someone someone in
finance and said well we cracked the
numbers
and um yeah for that new studio that
y'all gonna have and what is it
australia or whatever
yeah we gonna have to charge a little
bit more for that's what this seemed
like your pockets
ain't right so we can't say evil
activision no more
we can't say all the excuses that we
used to kind of give them
because it feels unless they i don't
know something behind the scenes that
i'm
hoping they make me privy to purely
financial driven
and they need this money you going to
pay these shaders
you want them you're going to pay we got
it we got to put this money in the bank
we got big things we got to do
and that's what it feels like you know
and
i think the finance guy has won in the
room activision taught them well
yes yes yes yes that that's so i love
that you made
the finance guy ivantas's uncle that was
great
thank you
[Laughter]
yeah man it just that's the only thing i
can come up with you know because
they know that they've been around the
block they know us
they know that certain things are not
going to go well right so this seems
like okay you're in a rock and a hard
place
the numbers were tallied you know what i
mean and we've got to really
push this and i think that'll even say
like tess is not
going away like tess is here to stay in
the in
the most purest form as travis said
there will be no technical difficulties
going on with tests there will be no
issues on the back end she's
working flawlessly you know what i'm
saying
and that that's what it may be that's
what it just very may be and
the issue is to ease point how long
are we going to deal with it or to come
i should say but the community is going
to deal with it
you know if outriders let's say get
yourself together and stay strong and
you know there's other games that's
coming out and pulling away and let's be
honest the reason another reason why i
hurt me personally
is because prior to this point e
i was saying yo it's one of the best
season joe
catlin or whatever you know every
title whatever i call the catalyst sorry
there's a lot of names
every week and i'm like okay and then
right before outright it like all the
down
just dead stopped and then we looked at
the map and it was like
guardian games and banner and that's it
and it it just it just was like a a
sudden thought
and now i'm like i haven't played in
about two weeks we'll get into i
logged in for guard again so we didn't
get into it but it just seems like
there's no reason to log in so this
this one hit hard because this was an
easy win like
like okay you get us back get us hyped
for next season we know vlog is coming
like easy wins and then to see this is
just like
what you guys think man i don't know
i uh he's like
i think travis just had a heart attack i
don't i don't i don't know
earlier i was like i think you covered
it all i mean yeah
that's i i
there are there are better way like okay
so here's the other side of the question
let's go at this point
would you trade all of the issues like
this type of stuff
potentially support more content for
subscription destiny
do you think that ever has a point where
that makes more sense
justifies more gets rid of the eververse
puts more of the stuff in game
if it's a you know 10 a month so i mean
you basically have a subscription with
the season pass as it is
and again i don't think they could ever
justify it because world of warcraft is
like
monthly and you're getting these massive
expansions but it's like some of their
stuff takes a while
i don't think it'll ever work but it's
just like i don't think it will either
i don't think you want to go there
because we already have
a destiny that feels like they're trying
to up that
multiple player you know count and if
you have a subscription that's the
entire
game is to like keep people playing and
give them things to grind for
and part of the reason i don't play
world of warcraft in addition to the
fact that the gameplay is just
is that like they do make you play your
entire life
like you have to put your life in there
if you have to make it worth that
subscription and
you know warcraft's entire goal is to
like keep you in there as much as
possible so that you never
fall off that subscription and i think
that results in
shoddy content and overly excessive
grind it's like the exact
opposite of what destiny players i think
want
me is like a destiny player i consider
myself hardcore
and even i don't want to spend all my
gaming time in destiny like
i want to play other games and just log
on when there's good
new content to play do the seasonal
stuff i want to be a part of the
conversation
and then as soon as i get to that point
where i'm like thinking about playing
gambit i want to log off
i don't want to just like play
activities i know i'm not going to enjoy
just because
of the grind um just because they're
incentivized to do that and so
also the subscription model is sort of
going away in gaming in general this is
like just a game
a gaming industry thing which is like it
it's really hard to sustain it there's
only a few games that have ever done it
successfully including world of warcraft
with massive budgets and a massive team
dedicated to doing it and i think the
new model is more like the fortnight
model we're free to play
you know you give them free to play and
then and then you give ways to make the
money part work and i think bungie is
obviously working on that now
the problem with it is that they are not
fortnite they are a paid game
they charge you for seasons not just the
season pass for the seasonal content
they charge you for the expansions every
year when they come out
that sort of stuff is going to matter
more as they add more of this sort of
like piecemeal
premium or freemium type stuff um
and so i i don't think a subscription
will ever work i don't think that
bungie should ever try and i don't think
destiny players
would benefit from that deal i think
that we would get a
nightmarish uh gameplay experience
because we've seen how long it takes
them to roll out content
uh and and i don't think we want to see
a destiny where
their only incentive is to keep you
logged in as long as possible because
that's going to drive a lot of people
off the map there are breaking points
for people oh yeah there are there are
the teddies of the world who will play
even while they actively hate the game
the entire season just to keep their
uh you know invisible triumphs
friendship
score as high as possible but i am not
one of those people and i for sure would
be one of the guys who's just like i
can't keep up anymore
it's too much but at what cost you know
because i like to i like really like
destiny
yeah how much did it cost i mean that's
just one of those things i saw floating
around on twitter so it's always like
it comes up every so often should this
game be their way that's why i was like
at this point when like you know
everything comes ahead bring that
discussion back just to see where people
land on it is always interesting to see
because
that's the alternative and that will
turn off a lot of people there's a
reason people don't play
games like world and others that have
tried is like i don't want to
continuously it's like
i can like now with xbox i can literally
play these games for zero dollars what
the hell am i gonna it better be
absolutely amazing
if it's getting that side you know you
would the level of content
would have to be so stellar and
continuous to justify that from what
we've already seen from bungie
right like unless they just said hey
those forsaken expansion size things
that we said we're never going to do
again
with this service model the size of the
studio growth and this other ip that's
launched
that like that's the only way they could
ever like maybe justify it but even then
that's a reach because
they've they've stretched this so long
yeah
i don't think it would work it's just
one of those discussions that ever so
often kind of you know kind of polish it
off a little bit yeah i remember it was
like
the discussion back in the destiny one
early days and i think now
oh yeah it would be so tone-deaf because
like now the model is to lower
all barriers of entry to just exactly
your game like that's the that's the
game that's why game pass is successful
it's why they're taking away the
requirements for xbox live gold it's why
uh apex legends which is a crazy
really well designed shooter is free
like the whole game is free unless you
want you know the extra skins and stuff
like
that is the world that we live in and
uh a premium game that you not only pay
for but then also pay for every month
through subscription is
the exact opposite that's some dinosaur
stuff that's like
you know that's like the the the
the horse-drawn carriage and then the
the
age of the car like it just doesn't make
any sense yeah agree the
the model has changed it's exactly what
you said and it's all about getting
people in
lowest barrier of entry and once they're
in
you know then there's the micro
transactions and stuff like that
they've got that part down they've got
the right back dave
they've mastered they have nailed it
they're doing an exceptional job
with texas this is working overtime
never has any technical hiccups
as we've discussed exactly i'm setting
the gold standard
as far as making sure it's actually the
silver standard actually
hey i love it
for real man it's just yeah so you know
it's gonna be interesting it's gonna be
interesting this is like i said a a
definite low
low point in the in the history we would
definitely put this
as one of those check boxes remember
where you are when they did this
like this is one of the moments you know
and we got to see
you know i'm just very curious if
be interesting if we get any kind of
bend if we get
any kind of you know
concession you know that'd be surprised
if we did i'll be surprised too
yeah and you know let's see let's see
how it goes because you know next
season's coming
they seem very excited we know vlog and
all that stuff but
you know we got to be careful you know
you keep messing with people's goodwill
and
there's other games coming out and you
know people get frustrated so they
they've got to be careful
that's all i'm normally look classic
bungie
they'll show us a trailer of the new
season we'll go
crazy you know what i mean and then for
a minute all will be well in the world
but i am a little because it's my my
eyebrows up like i'm a little concerned
you know because at the end of the day
it's like how many times can you keep
telling someone yeah future's bright
yeah the future's bright but
look what you doing to me now you keep
stabbing me
now future is always tomorrow [ __ ]
yeah like you know sometimes people
you know they've had enough you know so
that's where i'm at what about you
yeah i mean i think we beat this one
literally to death until we see
just if they listen if they change
if they fold at all or if they're just
like
this is what it's going to be yeah and
then we'll just have to see
i yeah i said it before the show like
friends are honest with each other
we all love this game we all love bungie
we're on their side we want to be on
their side we could be their biggest
advocates but also
fans are the most critical of the things
that they love because they love it so
much
and uh love you bungie but like
this ain't it
say dog i feel you i feel you
what else is going on uh well what
kicked off this week the good old
festivities of guardian games
um basic idea you've got your new strike
playlist we talked about kind of how it
was going to work last week we got our
new strike playlist in there
matching all of one class into the
strike playlist
uh of course not test sorry wrong
character eva levante the grandmother of
the tower is back
so she is there for your bounty and
ghost acquisition to send you on your
ways to grind for your medals
and your contender cards on all of those
things i wanted to see how much you guys
had actually jumped into guardian games
how much you had done
that type of stuff and just kind of you
love it you hate it don't really care
what are you guys at have you done any
guardian games drivers
uh yes i've played every day gotten all
of my
basically what i'm trying to do is i'm
gonna log on every day
and i'm going to complete the uh
whatever the um what are they calling it
or there's like a focus is it the focus
every day daily focus playlist yeah
daily focus
i'm just going to do the daily focus and
get that done
and log off and then you know work my
way toward completing all the triumphs
and
completing the event but you know i'm
one of those guys i have a lot of titan
pride i
want titans to win i've seen titans near
the bottom
every uh every uh day so far but
but titans we we are persistent
and hunters are lazy they they're like
the teddies of the world where they get
all the triumphs and then they log off
and then they
you know don't come on for another three
weeks and i'm counting on that
and you know if titans can't win i say
give it to the warlocks because
you know i don't really respect hunters
and i think that we should give warlocks
what they've never been able to get in
crucible a win
and i think that this is this is their
chance to do that
you're doing so well
and you had to poke them
that's why i jumped into the guardian
games myself just to see my fellow
the locks were doing you know see how
we're doing you know
it's different it's interesting you know
i did the uh i thought the strike
specific um
what you call it like class specific
strikes were kind of kind of fun just to
see you know you're there with your bros
like a gimmick but at least it's
different yeah it's a little different
you know
we got the the laurels and stuff on the
floor again and
all right cool but you grabbed that up
but um no it was decent i've been there
i i jumped in
i got the quest for the um the catalyst
now for um
their apparent watch your video sir so
i'm just working on that and uh getting
my medals i'm like 25 or 50 i'm halfway
there
so i just want to get that catalyst
going because i have seen
yeah do your platinums they're easy yeah
i've seen that so so i should just keep
sticking with the platinum as long as
you got the lord like if you have enough
laurels do a platinum nightfall go in
there shoot stuff come back out if
you're out and do one gold in the normal
strike playlist once you've got enough
just as many times you can do the
nightfall one because it's 15. you have
to do four of them and you're done
yeah so it's like whatever your laurel
pickup if you're fast
if you're good at the laurel pickup then
or you're you know in the mix enough
cool
and basically just try and figure out
the most efficient way to make laurels
like titans can literally punch
almost every enemy hunters have a pretty
similar situation warlocks between
sun bracers and celestial fire and
floating you guys basically can throw
abilities all the time too so there are
a couple of efficiencies from last year
that are still there
yeah and then you're just rolling in
those things pretty much i was i was sun
bracering out
and just ability ability ability just to
try to get stuff my only complaint is
when they give you one of those strike
boundaries or whatever
that makes you use another subclass
that's why the knight falls better it
doesn't
yeah i'm gonna stick with nightfall
because at the end of the day like i'm
like i'm not switching
it's just annoying and then you can't
refund it for something else it's like
it's stuck
into that you know it's like stasis and
void for me and i'm like i don't
want to do that right now just switch
out your weapons this is the problem
with the event is that like
we're all strategizing on how to do the
event least painfully
yes and the event is basically driving
us to activities that
are already in the game that we kind of
already don't want to do
especially nightfall like the fact that
we're all doing nightfalls and let's be
honest we're all doing like the lowest
we're just doing it just to get through
it and so it's like oh yeah you know
what i really want to do in a depth
nightfall one of the most unrewarding
activities in the destiny playlist and
it's like
okay great and and you know it's like
it's like i was saying before like they
didn't really
put any time into this it's it's just
it's the same exact thing adjustments to
be some existence
dude it's the same thing as last year
and the adjustments
are that now you have a metal case that
artificially
limits you limits the amount that you
can actually carry
yeah and it it's it that is like kind of
the only change and so
you log on and there was like no fanfare
there's no like
you talk to zavala and he gives you
speech about how dope titans are okay
i'll give them that that was pretty
awesome but
which we actually already heard in the
trailer part of it so it kind of was
you know i i loved hearing him say that
like oh yeah titans delivered a shutout
that's now in canon dope
um but it's it's it it after that like
the actual activities it's like okay we
got a playlist where it
only match makes you with people in your
class all right that's kind of gimmicky
but then other than that what are we
relying on the same courses
bounties it's bounties that's what we're
doing
and what do they call the the things
that their cars
yeah the contender you mean bounties
yeah because those
working awful lot like bounties and
they're just bounties
so yeah the uh i i i'm really
disappointed that the live games have
become the live events have become sort
of like
predictable it's like oh during festival
lost we're gonna be in the infinite
forest
the the playable loading screen where
you just sort of
run around and and you know it's or it's
randomly generated um random and then
art yeah sorry it's not randomly it's uh
procedurally yes yes
yeah that's the that's the language
rolling its eyes through its head
yeah yeah we're going to be doing that
and then and then during this event it's
going to be
hey who has the most endurance to play
destiny when they don't want to
that's basically the mini game here um
and so yeah i
i i'm not excited about this but
i'm gonna do it and and
boy oh boy is that a thing that is in
the game
you're just beaming with excitement
right now
is anybody excited about this like every
conversation i've ever heard
is like the one that you and cog had
where it's just like hey what's your
method for getting through it as quickly
as possible without me wanting to just
like beat myself
unconscious
how efficiently can you do this so you
have to play at least a mountain you're
like
that feels like crap yeah i mean what if
we
wanted to play guardian games imagine if
we were excited to log on
and actually like like honestly
it's so here's what i would have done
yeah i'm in charge of guardian games and
this is just me spitballing i don't know
how hard it is to program i don't know
how good it would be
but let's say for guardian games this
year
it's all about crucible and we've
created a new game mode
that's a three-way and it matches you
with titans hunters warlocks
and the winner of the day is the people
that win
the class the ones the most crucible
matches and they could just
i mean how hard would it be to do like a
3v3 v3
a three-way uh crucible match obviously
the maps would be a little challenging
and
you basically never done you have three
control points so
you know use that but they've never
they've never done like a
a three teams match but like that's a
normal thing in halo and
and other multiplayer games where you
can kind of modulate that and then you
just go
okay now this is a unique activity with
a unique mode with a fun mechanic
i'd be logging on every day to you know
roll with my titan crew and blast
warlocks and hunters off the map and you
know that
that's like an interesting it doesn't
seem like again i don't want to be like
a cocky arm
arm chair developer but but like
it doesn't seem that hard and it's a
unique thing that like gets people
actually competitive because now i
almost feel
sorry for the winner yeah like the
winner of this contest
is the team that spent the most time in
destiny
grinding out these activities that we
don't like and is that really
is that a medal you want pinned to your
chest like
something to be proud of obviously it's
easy for us to say this because we're
not at the top of the leaderboard but
guess what
titans were last year and i was barely
excited about that because
i did guardian games every day of the
activity last year i logged on every day
just to do my part
right and do whatever the dailies were
and by the end of it i was just like
honestly i'm a little ashamed i did that
because
was it worth it for my tiny statue in
the corner next to zavala that nobody
ever looks at like
yeah i just it was such a i mean yeah i
got the gold ornament but at one
cost
yeah it's like the catchphrase second
place there buddy
yeah i don't know what's up with the
locks man we gotta talk about this
what's going on man not not doing too
well out here
uh i'm seeing that band is not raising
high enough for my liking
so we gotta get going we're just doing
what warlocks do
listen we're the students of the group
we just gotta get it together we're not
focused right now
you gotta get up out from behind your
book and go do stuff
you know we gotta go do stuff we read a
little bit too i think we try to read
the effectiveness that we ain't actually
doing
any of the events so if titans don't win
i'm rooting for you guys
as warlocks know from the days of
self-res second time is the charm
for you guys so
let's hope you guys have a little issue
there
they talked about that um what is it
that mccabe is it
pseudo catch up mechanic about that
sort of my my post last week on twitter
was like
look titans have the stacked against us
and we never complain
that's the titan way is we take it on
the chin
and we might still be able to win this
thing even with
the uh even with the the the
disadvantage that we're set at because
obviously it's no fun if titans just
stomp everyone like that
every single year like they don't want
to make that and if this were hunters if
hunters won last year and then this year
they came and they saw that they have a
disadvantage
they'd be whining on every
forum you'd never hear hunter get where
the whole
that's all i gotta say is i will not
complain about it because i think
it makes sense mechanically to give the
group that dominated
almost every day last year a
disadvantage i'll take it
and if we win then you guys all have to
suffer the fact that we won despite it
yeah that's going to be the best way to
say i'm not going to complain about it
hunters would i won't and you know if
titans can't win it because the
disadvantages are against us too great
then i'm rooting for the warlocks
because they can use a win quite frankly
i think jason actually says something
really good he's like i think something
like this is what the games competition
is about
versus competition the olympics are
about competing against each other
not against a clock or some other
arbitrary factor yeah like they need
like could you imagine i don't know like
a warlock like think about a pv
god forbid we do something for pvp right
you know what i'm saying
matchmaking warlocks versus that and
those players
that's so easy yeah yeah they already
proved they could do it with the strikes
playlist why couldn't they do with the
crucible playlist
maybe they will maybe maybe it's too
early in the event and they're going to
change that little
strikes titan to crucible titan or you
know that would be
that would be amazing but yeah you're
right it should be its own game mode it
would be so cool if it was against each
other this is
we wanted we wanted well in the olympics
what's a
like competitive like hockey right like
we wanted hockey and instead we got like
the high jump
where like everybody's like you know
going off on their own little course to
do the jump and it's not
head-to-head yeah i mean there's
definitely certain maps
like javelin4 there are very specific
places you could spawn each set of
people they'd be far enough apart
and literally just use the flag
locations of most of the map for spawns
would it be perfect no but you got
enough maps in rotation
use the control points as literally
spawn points again
i don't know what it takes to do that
and you could probably farm some people
but then the other team's going to come
in and wreck shop
and you could at least move people
around spawns and i'm not saying that's
like easy programming armchair developer
never actually won but like that's what
you're saying
have this be a competition we go in
strikes right now working together which
is fine
but it literally is like there's nothing
else really for it you don't go in
and even when you go in like a nightfall
it's not like oh you get an extra medal
because you
made the most kills like i could go to
nightfall and carry the other two people
they still get some laurels to pick up
and they get their medal it's like no
you came in last in this nightfall yeah
you suck get a bronze and i got a gold
because i came in first and that's like
that's you incentivize to like move
faster and push harder and like
yeah yeah and go a little more but it's
all just about
check the box turn the chain block my
battle pick up the next box check that
box turn it in get a medal and it's just
this loop of
and for me it's like so we haven't even
got to air pair in the catalyst yet
oh yeah i went through got some medals
i'm gonna have my vip status for a week
that's not good if you don't have your
vip status i don't know what you're
doing besides just taking a break
because that's like one and done with
your platinum medal on an adept
nightfall like they did not make that
really challenging to go for
but after i got the catalyst i'm kind of
like why am i in here
i if the triumphs are not compelling you
there is not much keeping you in there
besides once you're done with the air
apparent catalyst
there's not much there and then it's the
the the question of like
okay so if the hunters have the bigger
population
and they're going to get the biggest
influx at first if if this is an
accumulation of total points
which i never know if it's total points
or daily wins if it's total points
hunters are going to have like
the biggest influx in the beginning when
they have the advantage and then as
most people are going to trickle out of
this thing unless one class just decides
to all right guys
final week let's everybody log no one
cares in the final week
no one gives a damn when the bonus is
going to be there so it's like i just do
we'll be there it's like i'm a titan and
i'm probably not going to care that much
but
yeah well you got you let the out
writers guys just
you know get get your pocketbooks filled
so you know
it's like those dinners i'm just too too
you know i've been
i'm fat from strength over here from the
opulence from the dinners
you're yeah with this planet wine just
like yeah
i drink deeply on the outrider's bounty
yeah but they'll get you stolen
it's never entirely clear it's like yeah
they may have won the day and you get
your bonuses there but if it's an
accumulation of total points
the biggest influx is going to be in the
beginning hunter population at the
beginning
and the other piece i did see is the
fact that where's the vast majority of
players and trials which is going to be
your weekend players there are a lot of
hunters
especially in trails not saying there's
not the others but i think the hunt the
pvp base
does lean pretty pretty heavily into
hunters and that's who's going to play
your weekend
trials platinum cards and those are what
the most points so again just in
unless that like stack up is like 1400
more or 140 more whatever that stack up
is gonna be of ten percent a day
i still don't think it's going to be
enough i just think contracts are going
to have in the bag the whole time and
the weekends are probably not going to
help at all so
that's why i was like for me i'm like
it's fine i was like i got my catalyst
i got the only actual reward since i had
the same gun
they can't even like not a new gun not
an extra anything not a legendary
nothing coming from just like to turn it
just nothing new but the gun from like
you got a catalyst okay i got the
catalyst what else is there
this is good though i mean it's a 75
damage reduction it's not a bad gun
but again it's like the spin-up for me
is always weird i can
switch to like thunderlord because i use
that to like finish up the catalyst
i can switch the thunderlord pam fire
not like dead
i'm not saying it won't kill me but it's
it's just the way it functions it's not
a bad gun but just that delay in firing
as i was using it i was like oh yeah i
can remember why i don't love
this gun
yeah yeah like said he said it best
brother i mean i'm gonna get it
just because i have the gun already i
want to complete i want to get that
extra beefy shield and all that stuff
to maximize it but once that's done
yeah i'll be logging off and waiting to
see what's going on next
but yeah that's where i'm at with it i
just i can't you know the rest of this
time investment
i don't really care too much about the
bragging rights as much just i just
wanted to see
how it was going to look how it was
going to play you know and i've got that
i've got the feel of what it is
and like like you said travis like it's
basically that core
loop again you know and outside of the
catalyst i'm not really interested in
anything else
besides that so i'll be getting it done
and be moving back on to my other games
until they have the new hotness for me
to come back to
and hey i actually don't mind when
destiny has like not a lot going on for
a while like
you know we took a two or three week
break from fire team chat and it was
just because like
every weekend we were like is there
anything to talk about and we're like
not really
a lot we can talk about guardian games
once it comes up and now
obviously we have a lot to talk about
with armor synthesis but like taking a
break from destiny is not the end of the
world there are other games out there
and
absolutely i think destiny's at its best
when like
it gives you a great experience and new
content and then it kind of lets
people catch up for a little bit and the
conversation
kind of you know died down a little bit
i think that's fine but yes
agreed this this is not a good look
there are live events that are basically
just
like what about what can't feel good
about this activity right like
there's no way that they're like we
nailed it like this is really fun like
everybody's logging on
excited to play destiny now you know i'm
sure got their monthly active users up
but surprisingly you know i've been
looking on what is it um
xbox live most played i was very curious
to see how they're doing and they're
still hanging around top 10 which was
very
surprising to me because i figured you
know outriders out here moving
you know obviously i know they have the
the technical difficulty stuff going on
right now
but i was just like okay xbox one skate
i'm just curious
and i wasn't surprised right now where
you're saying what games are out right
now
no basically xbox has like this uh this
uh
live list the xbox most played uh on
xbox
when i came to xbox live now xbox
network that they say
i hate that it's so stupid yeah but um
yeah so you could pretty much
track it in real time what people are
playing
and i'm looking right now four five six
seven eight nine yeah
that's the still in the top ten shots i
was shocked
outriders was as high as three but now
they are
down to this six and it's
it's still in the mix number one is it
uh
it's always it's always oh no no it's
always war zone call of duty
fortnite grand theft auto apex legends
then call of duty regular nba 2 2k 21
then outriders roblox rocket league
minecraft and then finalizing you know
you know what's not surprising is that
almost all those games are free
and freedoms the ones that aren't free
are on game pass so
yes yeah yes i mean even on steam it's
number 17 so i mean players peak
you're looking at you know 50 60 000
players i mean it's not it
seems to be hanging around that number i
mean this season hasn't been
bad are we kind of finishing very good
yeah like it's been a good season is the
end of it a little bit lighter as we
kind of talked about but having those
breaks is a good thing
that's not bad by any stretch like
that's actually kind of fun to
have the break play are the things i
mean you had outrighters near
mlb the show like this little stack here
between now and the release of next
season is kind of stacked like you're
not gonna have enough time
bio mutants coming in may there's a lot
of stuff that's not that far away so
having these breaks is
honestly really nice it's just when as
you said when the live event comes out
are we excited about the live event and
i'm like it's an 1100 strike playlist
with modifiers like
none of those modifiers are gonna do a
damn thing to you anyway like you're
still gonna get through them it's like
oh no i take a little more airborne
damage
what's is this a grandmaster knight it's
1100 strike players who gives it
like that's not gonna change the way you
play through a strike no matter who wins
or who loses in theory
it's like it's fun that you know the
modifiers are there but it's on a
playlist where it does
not matter it's not going to give you
enough of an effect to make you play any
differently
play a little slower really get that
feel in there and then it's yeah keeping
us around for me
after the catalyst is done i don't i
don't have much incentive to touch over
the next two and a half years i just
don't
and to be completely honest if again my
situation where outright didn't happen i
would not have stopped
playing all right i always enjoy myself
so
you know it is what it is so you know
look they've they've got
they know what they've got to do you
know i mean so we know what the new
season is upcoming
again but i'm wit i'm with travis like
i'm at the point now where
these events are getting too predictable
and and and and when you you kind of
roll your eyes when you see
them when you see them and then when you
see iron banner sandwich between them
that's where i'm at you know and and we
and yeah i got to give you credit cause
you called it you
i when i was you know i was in my
honeymoon phase with this season and
it was still good i'm not gonna say it
was terrible season but you were like yo
so
after this what are they gonna do so i'm
like oh maybe they sneak in one secret
thing
and it was like no no you're gonna get
this basic you know
and you're gonna get uh the the guardian
games the same pretty much and
you know iron banners all day and it's
stuck in between it's always like
yeah that part of the seasonal formula
still needs work
it's still you know cause it sucks
because it really putting like a damper
on a great start to it especially
narratively what they were
they were doing so i'm curious to see
how they end it yeah
would you think it'd be better if they
did nothing at the end of the season and
just kind of let it ride
as opposed to do a live service event
like this that's underwhelming
or do you think that that this adds
something even if it's
kind of a nothing burger it's a nothing
burger
it's just it it's filler it's it's just
you know
artificial you know it just shows me
that you know the content
is still you know the seasonal kind of
distill
those flaws there's still those issues
where
it we're not satisfied as a base we're
still
having those damn i wish you know like
i think if we had again i know it's
saying like all they had to do was make
another prestige mission you know i say
like
i'm you know i'm being respectful but
you know those at least at the back half
of the season when they had
one right so that's why i'm looking at
it like well maybe they shouldn't have
did presses so
early now because i'm like as dope as it
was
we was in our bag with the narrative
every week with with um what cato
you know i'm saying kaido and now it's
like
nothing new like nothing new and i'm
sorry i think i think their problem
is that they have a seasonal model
because
they couldn't release pressage now
because there's a whole bunch of stuff
that you have to do week over week and
it's kind of part of the season there's
troubles attached to it
and so like now their model requires
that most of their content
come out in that first month or the
first month and a half because so that
you have time to get it all done
before the season ends if they didn't
have a seasonal model and they were just
thinking of it as like a
a you know string of content that kind
of gets dripped throughout
a year then then that wouldn't be a
problem but the fact that this is a
season
it's part of what like you're paying for
there's triumphs that you need to get
done this season
and collectibles that you need to get
every week that's sort of the problem
now like
at the end of a season we know there's
not going to be surprises
because they would have put it in the
season they they're not going to
they're not going to add something to
the season at the very end that is a
major part of it so
it kind of used to like they kind of
they didn't have this model that's the
difference of this model
like the season seasons you can
literally go season challenge one
through ten
well there's 13 weeks in the season yeah
those got nothing i mean they have
guardian games now but like
that is literally the seasonal
challenges are gonna be its thing now
they could make something that doesn't
have a triumph it's just like
this is a cool mission if they don't tie
it to anything else would be something
like they did before it was just like
this is a cool mission for a gun it's
just now in the game now they could
still do that theoretically
but they want it if they if they want to
tie it into these challenges
it's going to be front loaded if it has
these like scannables and weird ass
things to it
if it's just this is a badass cool
mission it's timed you got a challenge
for the gun
you can run it a couple times and go
unlock your catalyst cool like whisper
i still like the model of whisper the
time challenge the upgraded difficulty
run it multiple times to unlock your
catalyst you know you've got reasons to
go back in there for a challenge they
had the different weekly modifiers you
had to get all those like
there was a couple reasons to it you get
it like five times you're like cool i've
seen the mission like five times
now like harbinger's sitting out there
i'm like i don't want to go run
harbinger again just to get another
pinnacle drop
yeah it's something i could do but i'm
like i experienced that in the moment
i got my cool drops out of it i've
already got my gun this is just like
it's just doesn't have the same feel on
some of those so now the seasonal tie-in
as well
forces the early release if they want
triumphs and engagement and all of those
things that come in
now we have this front loaded stacked
season and an empty back end which in a
sense i don't
hate it just means the back end of these
seasons are gonna likely feel like this
with some seasonal filler event which i
hope has a little bit more to it because
as you said if it's just it's a strike
playlist with like you know that's
wearing a sash instead of a coat of
paint
it doesn't feel much different and i'm
i'm going to be in there for the gun and
i'm out
right i think i know what it was now you
guys are right about
that stuff what i was hoping for what
they have done in the past
was two things one the narrative
cinematic thing that was stretching to
the end
which stretched to the end right so it's
like okay osiris-busting and warming
what do you still might get that
right yeah that was one and then the
thing that i'm surprised that they
haven't done
is and i know not not everyone was a fan
of it
but i thought it was a cool attempt was
when they did
kind of that procedurally generated
real-time event
so remember we're sitting there waiting
for the comment you know
we're sitting there waiting for so like
i thought they would con
i get it still the jury still out of
this season but i thought
those things they were experimenting
with to use
more for future seasons and outside of
that what did we get did we get two what
did we get we got the
the tower yeah so i think that was it
but they again that was like a test for
them like they weren't sure if they're
going to do it in the future so
if if that was a success and something
they want to continue in the future
that's seasons away right that's like
that's like a season 15 thing probably
that they
started building once the first event
went well or and and
it also had issues so they didn't it
wasn't a perfect land for them so they
probably have a lot of feedback for
using that in the future but right there
we go
so i was like traveler and all my life
yeah that's right almighty yeah
i just thought they would
for 36 hours or whatever they did to
basically switching
to beyond light the only that's the
annoying part about
that though is i want them to implement
those better
yes almighty wasn't bad but then what
happened with the almighty did we go to
go explore the almighty is this a new
activity is there anything
no we had the traveler heal itself which
looks cool and we had all the ships fly
in but then you're like what are the
effects of that
we're gonna go over to europa and
completely forget that happened for a
little while
just keep when they tie the stuff
together is when the narrative feels
good like
the season with title and then the
battleground's unlocked and this we
finally got to go on the tank like
that's actually been kind of cool but if
the live events like hey here's this
thing
let me go over here to the other side of
my my narrative line and go follow this
thing
what about what about that over we're
not we're not touching that
okay all right that's the disconnect
sometimes between these seasons like
they want the narrative through line in
the arc and again they've talked about
that more in which queen to be their
real big focus to launch the last
trilogy but yeah those live events so
far
while they have been cool haven't done
much to add anything
personally good point and i just thought
about something that which i think we've
got in their defense
the the delay then aren't we getting a
delay to um
that's uh that's that's sort of what
part of why this season is a little bit
long
and why the season going into the witch
queen is probably going to be a little
bit long too
so i think they should just do fewer
seasons honestly like
they're they're doing so much content
and some of it feels like
they're a little stretched then and yeah
i'm sure they're getting better with it
over time but
there's uh i just don't i i kind of i'm
of the opinion that like
no guardian games might have been better
than what we got personally
and i'm not saying that to just be like
awful i just mean that like
a half-baked event doesn't feel great
and if they said
hey guys no guardian games this year
because we want to make we want to
rework it and make
the next guardian games like really good
that's that would be my preference then
you know i don't want to do the same
festival of the lost either i was about
to say the same thing
i i don't look forward to it it's it's
brutal just be like all right
i can't wait to hear the howling and the
spooky music
in the tower and then for that to be the
highlight of the entire event
is just brutal like i i just
i don't want it and so like i i just
think that
if they would take more time and and
just let destiny not
have anything to do for a little bit
because they're they want to do it right
are you applying an expansion pass model
sir are you
you seem to be moving away from the
season or you seem to be waiting when we
take breaks
i have always been a fan of that i'm a
weird destiny player and that like
i've never understood the whole need to
constantly play
i was kind of like open to guns not
having random roles which a lot of
people especially crucible mains
think is heresy but i as a halo player
well then you balance
a game where the sandbox only has 13
guns and it's very well balanced
i saw the the power of that and the
reason people liked it
i'm not saying random roles is bad it
does add something to the game but the
reason they wanted it was the wrong
reason
they wanted it because they were like
give us things to grind for
and i say if you want randomized rules
you do it so that it
mixes up the sandbox and gives different
levels of power and you can kind of
adjust your preference that's the reason
to do it
the only reason the community wanted it
is because they were bored and they
wanted
destiny to be the only game that they
play and i get that from like a streamer
perspective
if this is your only game you kind of
have like a lot of eggs in your basket
and it's like
it behooves you to like push it as like
i want this
to always have content but for me i've
always
my goal is to never hate destiny and so
anytime i start to feel
like a little bit you know burned out
i'm just like bye like i've got 2 000
games installed on my xbox there's no
way
that i need to be spending all this time
in destiny so if i'm not enjoying it
i'm out i don't need to complete
everything i don't need to get all the
collections i don't need to complete
and teddy and i agree on almost
everything except for this
crazy like thing in his brain that needs
him to just have it all he's got to
collect everything
bro dude that's like that's psychotic
behavior man i mean i said that when you
we were on the show together
but it was a psychotic feeling daddy
like you know
i you're making you're making some good
arguments i definitely hate your
perspective
i definitely appreciate you coming from
as far as you know you don't want to
hate it so you
for your perspective you're like yo i'd
rather them not even do a half-baked
kind of event
because it's not i know i get it i get
it you know i
i was there at one point even though you
know i said i was there and that
you know i've tried to accept this
seasonal model and i do feel they've
made tremendous improvements
with narrative and that to me is what
has me holding on and it has me saying
okay
they continue so don't go for it
i was thinking about this when ubuntu
was talking about it too and like
i've said on this show before that i'm
sort of a pessimist when it comes to
destiny's storytelling
and i was thinking about it this week
because there's been another news
headline
yep about a similar franchise that got
me thinking about destiny which is the
game of thrones thing
so i don't know if you guys saw in the
news this week but they they said like
they're going to do a 10-year
celebration for game of thrones
because game of thrones started 10 years
ago and but it ended two years ago and
so one of those things where people are
like well this seems too soon didn't the
show just end and we're already
celebrating like
oh remember that great show and the
thing about game of thrones is
the reason people loved it is because
there was all this lore all these
promises made based on this like kind of
vague storytelling of like
who are the white walkers and like how
are all these little plots connected
and then people ended up hating it
because in the last season it turned out
that it was just a house of cards
none of that meant anything and it was
just like
ways to kind of like titillate you and
then the ending was just like
you know put together typical action
movie with like
really none of that depth there was no
payoff but i worry
all the time the destiny is that i worry
that like destiny is like setting up all
these little tidbits and we're like ooh
there's stuff coming down the pipe it's
going to be really cool
and then when it gets here we're going
to be like wow that was really stupid
and not worth eight years of like
building
right and i that is like my worst
fear because you always like with
destiny
you're always saying god i hope this is
worth it right now i hope that like
being a part of this community and all
the time i've invested
is worth it and in game of thrones you
can only invest so much time you can
only watch that show so many times but
destiny
thousands of hours you can invest your
life in destiny
and so there's going to be people whose
whole identity is this thing and if
you get let down by sloppy false
promises where all these loose threads
aren't tied together in the end
it's gonna be a nightmare yeah that's
literally what game of thrones
experience that final season because
it felt like the most rushed you know
non-satisfying payoff of all these
threads
and those were people who only dedicated
dozens of hours if you've dedicated
thousands there's going to be riots in
the street from
players they don't get the ending they
want and i feel like
i feel like even if bungie does an all
right job of tying all these loose
threads
together which i frankly think is almost
an impossible task
but even if they pulled it off they
will probably not pull it off to the
satisfaction of everyone
and they kind of set themselves up for
failure because they
can't please everyone because everyone's
going to have different opinions
of what should happen and how it should
all come together and they've put so
much
time into this game that their
expectations could not be higher and
their opinions cannot be stronger
and no matter what there's gonna be a
faction that's pissed off
and and if they managed to do what game
of thrones did and piss off virtually
everyone
i'm worried man like i this is what
keeps me up at night
besides having dreams of missing the
show this is the other thing
i mean hey we got priorities and i'm
glad we're one of
only oh them i'll say one last thing
i'll give it to you i'll finish up
i definitely these are valid these are
valid concerns like
you're preaching you're preaching
preaching right so
all i will say is again
this that it's that blind faith that
blind
hope that we always put in them but
in their defense they always seem
what's that like shy that's a darkest
hour like
whenever they're at their lowest they
always have this
the darkest night is just before the
dawn or something like that they always
have this tendency when we're just to be
like
that's it and then they do it and you're
like
oh my god but the problem is they don't
stay consistent enough
that they stay in that bag and just keep
in that bag
throughout but they'll they'll do it and
and the last part i'll say is
you know with the restructuring and luke
and now knows worthy
being now the or usually they're being
the george rr martins now
right now we're taking this thing and
we're really invested in this floor
we're really
gonna take this thing and whether it be
movie or whatever it is
like there isn't it what gives me hope
there's an investment
to the lore to a point now where they
want to take this further so part of me
says okay
we see the future plan we see the the
initial road map that he was talking
about you know witch queen and all that
stuff
right it's up to them to pay that off i
agree
but when i see them invest and move
position in that way
then i see long-term vision i see okay
well that gives me hope that there is
structure here that there is something
they're not just
willy nilly out here this you know i
mean i actually have a
light versus dark saga like we have an
end in this final
trilogy starting with witchcraft they
planned out like we need another
expansion to tell all the pieces
again big giant fear this doesn't go
well
but they at least they literally have a
three-year plan like
beyond light seems to have definitely
been a buffer it seems to definitely
have been that in between
had some ideas got to work some stuff
out right
they have a through line to whatever
they're going to complete the game as
whether it goes into tv movie and other
stuff after that but at least
again that's the thing it gives me a
little bit of hope right like you're
saying
but it also gives me a crap ton of worry
that it's going to end
and it can't deliver so no doubt the oh
just to tie it back in to um to travis's
point
with game of thrones what did gamer
throws in is
j.r martin george martin the books
wasn't finished for that last part
so now their version of luke smith
they're just
winging it they're just and they're
trying to put a bow on something that
just
ended badly whereas we still have our
you know to be martin still working
still doing stuff
and that's the only reason why it's okay
i'll give them hope and shout out to the
cops go by
but that's what i feel i mean i hope
you're right again it is always like the
act of faith that every single destiny
like long time fan has to like
eventually kind of admit that they
they have but the expectations are so
high the odds are stacked against them
and you know i've even if like for
example
the witch queen sabbath if sabbath done
doesn't feel like a satisfying payoff
and we just whoop her like she's oryx
and the taking king
that that alone has like four or five
years of setup
behind it that are going to be hugely
disappointing so i
i just think uh the expect they're
almost in a lose-lose situation
even if they managed to pull it off now
um but yeah
we'll we'll we'll see uh we'll see what
happens and uh i'm obviously rooting for
them
i don't think that announcing the end of
the dark saga is something to be like
yeah through confident about that's
basically just like game of thrones
announced
the final season season eight you know
what i mean that's not that doesn't mean
it's in the bag
that just means it just means that
they've announced oh you gotta dab
nice dab perfect god you're such a [ __ ]
make me die for a thousand points like
come on what are you doing
what are we doing here i love it i took
the exercises out today because i got a
lot of crap behind the green screen but
yeah they're usually there
i think it's like i got nothing else to
spin it on i'm gonna make him do this
yep great not fair but like you said
fair
realistic you know i i completely
understand where you're coming from
there's nothing wrong or incorrect to
feel that way
and like i said it it's valid you know
it's just a matter of perspective i want
to believe i'm with kuk
and spirit inspired that's where i'm at
with it
yeah i mean my big fear is obviously
can this thing actually pay off because
i mean you said it right there savithoon
already as witch queen is supposed to be
setting up the dominoes going into
sabathune who's
and we've already seen a little bit of
zebra wrath we've still
let you know savathun be departed from
all of this interaction are we ever
going to get to face her is it going to
be a big deal are they going to do a
dramatic death against
you know are big events actually going
to happen in something where which queen
were like oh damn stuff's actually going
down
can they get to that level or will they
commit to again we don't know we have
like the
dark vanguard or whoever you want to
call the other ones out there
they're just gonna be they're just gonna
make me do it a hundred times and then i
got travis in here too it's beautiful
you got a double we got double for your
double double dab a little daba do you
oh
um so it is that idea of like sabbath
already sets a precedent of is the other
two years gonna be worth it
this could be a start but i'm like this
lightfall
you keep wondering how much farther
they're gonna stretch this stuff out are
we gonna
are we gonna have light versus dark
subclasses is the final year of destiny
2 going to preview be like hey as you
guys play through the story this is
going to lead into destiny 3.
is it going to be just hard finish and
then we go into a tv show
nobody has a freaking clue right now
they have an idea which is good
and they have at least a plan of one two
three years and this is where we in the
saga the fact that they at least are
like
this is where the messy beginning
happened which we didn't quite know what
has happened with the story we've at
least got a point where we want to kind
of wrap this you know weird ball of wax
up and then go on to the next one
part of me that was wondering how these
seasons are going to work with the
delays like bringing it back to our
current season
we haven't seen the calendar for next
season yet i am dying to see that
calendar
to know how long season 14 is is it
gonna be a three-month season
front loaded story and the next one's
like a
seven month season or however long it
needs to be
but overall it's one like that's kind of
one of those that
he's bad right now oh he's just he was
five points
to make me do it about 100 times he's
out of control
see i got both there you go
i'm sorry i had to no no you're good
that was funny
but that's kind of the piece that i
wonder how they handle
all of this timing and they have three
years out there planned
but as you said would people feel better
about this the expansion model to go
back a big chunk or at least do they go
back
is it always going to be the seasons
this is always this constant like
movement that bungie has to go through
to try and be like
how about this season do we front load
it or do we extend it out do we put a
sacred mission here and it's this ever
moving target we're like we don't know
what we're gonna get i missed one oh
posture check nope sorry
all right there you go e i got this
solution
based on your base of based on me
observing you
recently the past month with a certain
other game i got the solution
all that does not matter all they got to
do is give you alma 3.0
with exactly the way art riders does it
and you will not care about any of this
story where it goes
because as long as you get that
customization that mid-maxing that you
love
you gonna be good so i say they just
need to straight up
rip off the outriders system as far as
arbor and city choice
give you the gear sets give you that all
that
that minutiae that you love and i love
to
and uh you ain't gonna care what
happened with 17.
no i was like and that would be the
other thing but you want to know why i'm
worried about that
because we already have technical
limitations on legendary weapons
what weapons what remember you the armor
guy okay
if they can't do it to a character basis
with one more thing on a legendary
weapon
i'm worried that set bonuses are
functionally something they may or may
not be able to do
that's what they say they figure it out
let's just say that and i was like and
if they do
last but again we'll be good i would
definitely be in a lot better shape i
can promise you if armor builds skill
trees
rpg stats if this stuff was actually a
thing
in destiny it would be the game i've
been asking for for a long time
and if they have some of a compelling
story to go through
to get to that journey i'd be happier
100
believe me it's like the narratives have
has made leaps forward and honestly
getting about seven eight weeks in
narrative
that's actually been quite a bit of fun
the drip feed still kind of like
be like but at least it's not like 14
weeks per se
but overall for me it's the now when we
see
technical limitations on old armor sets
we see
technical limitations that legendary
weapons can't get another perk another
slot
because if we add one we're gonna break
another perk when i see those types of
things
but when i see those types of things i
wonder
is that like how could you do how deep
is it possible
how deep can they really go with an
armor 3.0 that in my head
doesn't even feel possible you got 14
more you got skill trees that look like
outriders and you can go deep those
don't even seem like a feasible option
have like
10 different perks applying to your
character plus an armor set
with set bonuses and mods that do more
like that doesn't even seem in the realm
of possibility until the d3
until they completely like finally get
rid of
the old stuff so that's where the
narrative seems cool but the journey
along the way feels like it's going to
be potentially a bumpy rough or
fairly samey road the events if armor
isn't fun that type of stuff is
kind of where my worries are because the
narrative could be fun but the systems
to get there might be real
not fun you know what they should call
set bonuses
on destiny's armor armor synthesis
that one's already taken they can't
and as we bring this full circle and i
don't know
um yeah that's like there's a lot of
speculation but i'm dying to see the
calendar
is this going to be a five six month
season is this going to be three in the
nine
like i'm that one tells me some of what
we're looking at
and then on the other side has just got
to be yeah as you said
which queen really sets the tone that
expansion has so much on it and for me
that's the one
take the time you need there are going
to be these other games and i'm totally
fine like that break from destiny
especially if it's like hey they do a
three month season three month season we
need like nine months and we're gonna
release it when we're ready you know
what
there's other stuff to play now people
are gonna be like trials and iron and
that's the hard part
for other people to be like we don't get
anything for like six seven months in
destiny
that's a hard pillow for some pillow
pill
for some people to swallow don't swallow
pillows you'll die um
but that would be a hard pill for some
people to swallow but that may be what
they need to be like we just can't
keep doing the live service it's just
like focus up on something new take the
break
and come back with a banger that's
i'm not our that's what they did with
the taking king
it's just anybody had any regrets about
the 10 king we didn't get all the
content and then the taken king came out
and completely refreshed the game and
rejuvenated every and brought the player
base back even larger than it was before
anybody got a problem with that model no
one
[Laughter]
i think if they leave people with a
decent taste like
shorter season don't drag it out too far
if they do the shorter season don't drag
it out too far and be like
at this point we want to hunker down and
focus on this next thing
and the new reds in there longer seasons
for the win
they can give you hey iron banner is
coming up they'll post it on twitter
trials maps are going to be there you
have fun maybe they actually do a
festival
lost and waste your time with that one
too i don't know but
again it's like me i would rather them
just be like just put everybody in
put everybody focus on the next piece i
would personally be better with that
again just because
that's when it's at its best and this
one has to crush it
to start what they want to start it does
need done well
fair enough i feel you
are you not on board would you rather
see the longer season
okay i've always been i've questioned
for both season guys do you guys want
like
three three breaks do you want like five
or six and five and
however long these are do you want crash
shorter current like link
seasons and then just a break till the
game or do you guys want him to like try
and space two seasons with
filler stuff until it's like hey we in
the season to this thing like where do
you guys want to see it go
travis um i would like to see
fewer seasons i don't care if that is
longer seasons or shorter seasons and
then nothing in between
i just want it to be more manageable
because
bungie has talked about a lot in the
past about how their workload is not
sustainable
and how it wasn't sustainable under
activision and now the current model
seems like
their their solution is oh we'll just
make the content
really grindy and simple and repeatable
like we'll just make it or like okay you
have to just do this for like a long
period of time
um and i think that the the story
has been great in these seasons and the
content like this season was pretty good
but
uh the longer that you go on with it the
more you know repetitive it gets and the
fact that they're
still saying hey we're in the season and
expect more content is kind of the
problem so maybe they should have just
ended the season early or just made the
expectation that
they're going to let people catch up and
that there's not a whole lot coming
and then when they do stuff like
guardian games a live event
either make it good and something worthy
logging on that has some uniqueness to
it
or just don't do it because you're just
you're giving your game more exposure
where people are kind of like getting
exhausted about it like
i the times i feel best about destiny or
when i've gotten a break and i come back
and there's a ton of you to do because
it's a
launch day and the worst times i've had
with destiny
are when a new season launches and i
just got done grinding out the last
season and i had to play all the way up
to the wire
and then a new season comes out and it's
basically a carbon copy where i'm doing
a different type of event
there's a little uniqueness to it but
then two weeks later i'm like dude i was
burned out before the season started
and now here i am in this new season
already like
not wanting to play and so i think they
do themselves a disservice by releasing
content frequently that's half baked
on a really like rigid schedule and i
would rather than have to come up with a
model that's more sustainable
not just for the developers but for the
players who
may have burnout issues and who may
have trouble doing you know strikes
gambit and crucible the three pillars
over and over and over again with very
little uh
little change like guardian games has
actually no change
it's literally just do the same
activities that you've always had access
to
no new maps for crucible no new strikes
no new gambit maps like there's nothing
new
about guardian games nothing yeah just
bounties
like i said you're preaching you know
this this was probably my literally my
initial argument when um seasonal model
was
announced and that this was the route
they were going i was pouting i was
pouting you know i was in that same
you know you know same side as you it
was just like you know um
i i like when when we do come back that
big
me taken king size portion of oh my god
it's so much to do
we knock it out and then and again
that's why i'm always gonna die on the
sword i still was always felt the d
d2 evolved and made quality of life
better than d1 yes
but d1's model to me was the best
destiny i i still i'm dying on that
sword because
i i remember those times when again the
rise of iron or the
the king finally hits and you're like
yes it is just so much to do and you're
completely invested
and then when you finally done you take
a break you go away you play other stuff
and then you're just more rejuvenated
when it did come back
in the fall or whatever that september
was you know in a seasonal model i have
tried to give it a chance
you know they've improved yes but
there's still
issues you know i mean there's still
issues and and i'm kind of leaning your
way drivers where it's like
sometimes it's like do we even re did it
like it could have ended
right when the whole dope cinema with
um you know the crow and then we could
have been like all right
we could end it right and i'd have been
like yo it would
you know it was a nice portion you know
what kind of thing so
that's the thing but when like you said
you made a great point when you come
right back
after you finish doing all that grinding
to do a similar
samey kind of event for the season
and stuff like that outside of the
narrative improvements and the voice
acting all that great stuff
you know that's the redundancy so yeah
we
you know that that's where they're at
right now and and resources doesn't seem
to help them to be able to
prove that they can continue to do it
for a long period of time so maybe like
he is saying
take that break just say hey you know we
have delayed such and such we're all
hands on deck
for whatever which queen or what have
you
and you know see when we see you because
it's a good point like i didn't have
like there's certain things i'm like yo
i'm not
doing that when you see a season one i'm
like when you see that part of the map
i'm not doing that yep and i'll be like
i'll see you
past that kind of thing so then it
becomes what's the point of
you know see because it can't be just me
that's feeling that way so
yeah you know it is what it is they're
they're an interesting spot and
you just hope but if the either the
resources improve for them to continue
this model
or if not like you said don't do it make
season shorter
less content or expansion model and
whatever but the problem is
last point they're successful with this
that's the problem they are success not
that i'm wishing anything bad for them
not to have success
but i just showed you the engagement
on where they're at as far as a player
account and stuff like that
you know we're seeing tess out here
moving and shaking
you know what i mean so they're doing
well
with a model that the hardcore don't
necessarily
like and it's hard to move someone off
their square
in that situation that's the problem
right now in my opinion
you mute it sure you don't have a cool
light you don't have the cool light you
need the cool light
yeah i know old mic lights up no no
i got you that i got a little light i
need a big giant
white strobe in my face um
no but it is that weird thing of
our almost everybody who probably
listened to this
listens to this podcast especially
because we're not that big is a vocal
minority
or a very much a minority hardcore
player who seeks out a destiny podcast
not like i mean the igm podcast has a
lot more eyes on it
and your guys opinions probably still
are probably going to mirror most of
what we said because you're obviously
one third of it but
on the other side is how many people
are making up that quantity of people to
play
that are gonna be you know don't listen
to podcasts don't really care about
youtube videos may look up a guide how
to get a new web and that is
it they don't they just care about how
to get the thing everything else is just
like i play my two hours a week and
slowly work through this thing and
got some stuff to work on and still got
some challenges to knock out
mm-hmm and they may not even give two
they're like cool long season drip feed
it out it's perfect for me
and that may be a lot of people and
we're not just the other side of
the minority we're the grumpy old man
that's what it is that's what it is yeah
we have
more times for video games yes so it's
like now the middle-aged people who are
trying to play these games with families
jobs and everything else
some find less time some people have
three kids to deal with and like man i
get my hour while trying to
manage all this stuff and that's all i
got and that's the piece where bungie is
looking at
the data and the other sides of things
to say maybe
what we want is really not what's
working because 80
of the player base may be like we're
great their surveys that they send out
every so often may honestly tell other
other than what we want that's the key
no you're absolutely right and because
you know how many people tell me hey man
i still haven't done
somebody's got to run me through the
raid man i never i've done deep stone
they're the majority and like we all
know bungie loves their metrics
they have to be sitting on these metrics
they have to be sitting on where people
are
season stuff like that and i think yeah
i think that what what has happened
sadly for us and we're going to have to
adjust
you know well that's about all we got i
know i've been here for a minute i feel
like we need to let travis try and get a
nap if possible
for real uh so we can get into the races
man i gotta find the team chat going and
i have yeah we gotta get them going i
have to come up with some new roast
options for
yeah you know your ears will come out
before
well maybe not we'll see when i get it
up yeah they'll probably pop out at the
same time so you won't overlap too much
um but man thank you very much for
coming on i know this was early but
had to have you for the spicy chat this
morning it was worth it
one clip a day all week long we're gonna
have so many lines this week it's gonna
be hilarious so
no thank you very much for coming on but
yeah let him know what you got coming
you got any reviews you're working on
that you probably
can't talk actually i'm working on a
preview uh it's an ign exclusive
uh for a uh announced game but i'm not
allowed to talk about the preview but
it'll be coming out next week
um it's a a very exciting game uh
and i'm working with ryan mccafferty on
that so be on the lookout for that it'll
be on my twitter
um and then uh for
uh fire team chat you can watch us
tonight at 5 p.m pacific
we're on uh every other week now
although we've sort of just
decided we're going to do it whenever
there's something i talk about so
um right now that this week is
definitely going to be a fun one we got
brian myself and dustin so the original
cast and paul cassie is
taking the week off in shame since his
uh
his destiny has become this frankenstein
monster that he's unleashed on all of us
and i
fully blame him um and then uh yeah
that's that and and
obviously you can you can watch me here
on the iron lords podcast
oh my my most beloved uh
i was beloved uh sorry no you could see
me here on the last word
i was like wait a minute they haven't
had me
[Music]
the spicy hilarious tanks yeah it's it's
a great time so
yeah officially people so thank you bro
cannot wait i know i was actually
talking to you offline but honestly like
guardian
khan or gcx in 2022 dude did not come
soon enough
seriously like i cannot wait i'm
vaccinated give me my booster i will be
there so
yeah or not i'm definitely gonna be
there so that is
that is what i'm looking forward to so
yeah thank you very much for
the early rise so hopefully you can
probably pass out tonight whenever you
need to go to bed fairly easily since
you were up
before the sun yes what about you
what do you got coming anything exciting
that people can look forward to
with you possibly possible stay tuned
yeah watch watch this man's twitter
let's just say
watch lord cognito's twitter like a hawk
well yeah you ain't gonna want to miss
this one it's some fun something fun you
know that i'm looking forward to
hopefully should be releasing soon and
um yeah it's a lot of fun so
be on the lookout i'll be putting that
out there soon it was
definitely a lot of fun he knows what it
is but he's the only one
you know i keep everyone to secrecy like
i tell my man
but um yeah other than that um this week
again check out ironwood's podcast it's
been a fun run we've had some good
guests we'll have another one
the great paris lily will be joining us
so
check that out he finally was able to
fit some time we've been working it for
like about
a couple of months some busy people hard
to nail down sometimes so
absolutely absolutely so yeah that
should be fun we'll definitely try to
sneak a little
that's the in there but it's going to be
mostly about what's going on with the
industry and stuff like that and uh yeah
um
obviously uh loads of gaming.net really
appreciate that
all the hard work that's been going on
with that the site and
people checking that out and just for
people um i want to shout everyone
show some love when i've been making a
lot of podcast rounds lately
so a lot of them everywhere yeah who's
been showing love
and and really supporting has been
really cool and i really appreciate
it's been very very humbling very
humbling to see so yeah you got that and
of course that last
word with my man ibottus talking that
talk we had the amazing travis in here
always fun man
you brought it today brother like i
would just say i was like let him go
just let him go
[Laughter]
open them up let them out on the road
just you're roam free out there man
they're clutch exactly every day it was
a pleasure as always brother a lot of
fun and
eat what you got going on man what's
going on with you bro
uh for me yeah i mean it's kind of the
balance of
a little bit of outriders a little bit
in this i made my first
no i did second episode of ori two
so will the west dude that two out i
gotta say the two hours it was maybe two
and a half hours like because it was on
wednesday play little guardian games
kind of working with the shot and stuff
like that so i was trying to make sure
my arm wasn't gonna like kill me or
anything
but i like kind of switched over to ori
in the middle of the stream
about three hours dude i had to turn it
off dude i cried twice
bro nice i was like dude i love that
game
oh man that one hit me i was like all
right twice all right
we gotta like we gotta okay we're gonna
get to a stopping point i'm gonna shut
this down because if it does this to me
another time today i'm out so yes
no ori one was good ori ii was just like
hitting even better i was just yeah so
no that was that one's a blast depending
on what i got going on this weekend i
might jump in for another episode of
that but
that has been fun um and there's a lot
of stuff just sitting out there just
that i'm itching to try i mean you've
got
near there i think it's literally
dropping today
it came out today so fraternal uh i
threw my name in the hat for code we'll
see what happens
nice um but like i haven't played
automata but like skillups review
makes me want to play near automata
because like he's these like this is the
like the game you should play that you
probably won't and it's one of those
where like you got to get about 10 hours
and then it just like hits
and i think both of them are going to be
that way so yay
so i actually think that game is great i
i think i reviewed it for some outlet
but i read one about
uh replicant that was like about 10
hours in so i don't know about
automobiles oh replicant okay okay
sorry i don't know replicant i haven't
played it yet but nero automata like
i liked the game for like the first
playthrough which was like 10
15 hours yeah like i want to understand
like there's multiple playthroughs so
yeah
it's multiple routes but you basically
have to play through the game four
different times
yeah the second the second playthrough
is just as long as the first except for
it's awful
and so like you spend like 15 hours
playing a really good game
and then another 15 hours playing a
really bad game
and that is also a repeat of the exact
same game you just played but with worse
mechanics
and then you play two smaller campaigns
after that that are each like five
hours but by that point if you're like
me you just hate the game
because you just you just had to play 15
hours of a game you didn't want to play
and so then then everybody goes oh but
after the first two playthroughs it
really takes off and i'm like dude
after the first playthroughs i didn't
want to play at all so like i was just
mad at the game uh by then but
uh the first 15 hours was like great and
i wish i would have stopped there so
that's my only
suggestion ign needs to let you do video
reviews in this format
i agree i think you are hilary like
you video review just narrating your
feelings about play-throughs
has to be so we got to speak to the
higher-ups
you want the hot takes this man will
give him to you with all the that's
true that comes with it somebody sent me
in a dm
a word cloud of my twitter and my like
most used words and they were like
all horrible like phrases like
kill and stuff like that and then right
in the middle of the word cloud in the
biggest font possible
clunky
i love it
yeah that would be amazing so yeah it's
like just as i said guardian games had
me for about a day and a half and i'm
kind of done so it's just
you know waiting to see how the season
wraps up other than that you know a mix
of other things in between and just you
know having fun
hanging out with you guys on twitch and
of course these episodes these
fridays are always fantastic travis i
don't know like my cheeks hurt after
you're on like we're cracking up and
laughing the whole time so it's good
times when you're on here we have a
blast
thank you guys all whether you are
lurking if you're new drop the follows
go
find travis on twitter it's time guy
travis
follow him it's worth it definitely for
the takes
lordcognito
ironlordspodcastlordsofofgaming.net
follow all of these gentlemen
they are amazing you guys are awesome
i'm going to see you guys over to zoe
previous
awesome lady who is on she's running
some gm's this morning so since i'm love
over to zoe
you guys are fantastic but for this
episode
april 23rd am show with the two awesome
gentlemen around the campfire it has
been
the last last word